here
hello how's it going everybody don't
mind me I'm like in the middle of
fighting stuff we made it in though we
didn't have loading beats loading screen
simulator we were trying to play you the
loading screen for days we thought that
would be fun but we actually got in this
time and it looks like they worked out
most of the kinks from the VIP demo
which is cool by the way happy Friday
everybody it is 10:00 a.m. which is the
time that mornings actually start
everybody knows that and we are gonna be
playing some anthem open beta today so
many of you can get into this actually I
think most people can get into this not
to be confused with let me get you guys
over to our gameplay not to be confused
with the the various release release
dates where there is a handy dandy
infographic over on GameSpot calm data
infographic when can i play though aaron
it's not too crazy actually it looks a
lot crazier than it is but the honest
truth is if you're an origin access
subscriber you get to play on the 15th
for 10 hours if you're a super origin
access subscriber you just get to start
the game on the 15th and pretty much
everybody else is on them twenty-second
so yeah sometime between the 15th and
22nd you you can play at them
also there's a we won't be streaming it
but if you're gonna play them the open
beta there's actually a been an event
T's for Sunday although I think Tay
pointed out there might be some ball
sports going on Sunday as well it's the
Super Bowl man so uh for anyone that
cares about that I guess we should care
because it's on cbs.com or CBS Sports I
guess I'm too busy watching you actually
CBS but what's up too busy watching the
Navy SEAL show on CBS which I absolutely
friggin love dude I have not played
interceptor and this is kind of crazy
how much better than me okay so what's
happened since the VIP demo well for
starters you can play the game which is
good they sorted most of that out by the
second day of the VI
demo and the really interesting
conversation that's people have been
going after this morning are combos so
anthem takes the a combo system very
similar from Mass Effect's co-op and
it's a bit more complex now so depending
on what class you've already played or
you're going to play you need to start
thinking about what combos do so there's
primers and there's detonators and you
can either some some classes are good
solo at doing both so like the Colossus
it doesn't regenerate health but it can
use things like the shock coil on the
flamethrower to set up its own
detonations and then the other classes
are good for different things so for
example the Ranger
when the Ranger detonates a combo it
does the most damage versus single
enemies so the Rangers really good for
for like the big bosses whereas a
Colossus kind of sucks against the big
bosses they're more like minion clearing
when I was playing Colossus it felt okay
like it's I guess the one stronghold
boss that is available if you could crit
it it did okay yeah but I used it
actually to be honest I used the
ultimate more to like get my life back
then I did to actually do like it does
big damage still but if you're ever low
on life it's almost like when you're
playing God of War and you use like rage
yeah to that point I think the Colossus
is actually a lot more of a boozer core
build than a tank it's actually not a
tank build and i think it's a bit then
they had clear right yeah the names a
bit I don't know the name of voc's the
wrong idea I've actually heard from some
people who play this class that this is
a bit more of a tanky class because of
because it's more melee base yeah
because more men living in their face so
with the Colossus which is when I played
the most you need to actually manage
your shield because you don't regen
health you need to actually pull out
your shield and use it properly or
you'll just die quickly it's one of the
big things that they do also the
Colossus when they when they detonate
they have like an area explosive effect
that the other classes don't have
however the storm and the Interceptor
when they detonate in different ways
both spread their
primers out to enemies around them so
ever it's I would suggest reading up on
it maybe we'll write up a quick article
on it too it seems like the combo system
is the thing to do in this game also
it's it's even more important than
necessarily the power of your abilities
so like a lower level flamethrower
detonating combos on a colossus is more
important than not having it and having
like a higher level acid spitter so
we're getting into the nuts and bolts a
bit for those who play the VIP demo alls
I'm saying is pay attention to your
combo system if this is your first time
playing anthem maybe a bit more than the
the number above your ability or weapon
it'll definitely be easier to like pull
that stuff off with like teammates and
coordination of course I mean it's still
possible without it but yeah and crime
had to ask a good question it's like do
you think ice is like gonna be like
probably the best element I haven't
played enough or around it but I feel
like that's gonna be really good yeah
what's the meta I just feel like the
fact that you can free stuff and then
combo into it seems like too good to
like not have somebody have some type of
ice or like I'd almost always unless I
knew my teammates also we're running a
lot of ice as an element like feel like
I would probably be using quite a bit of
that action oh it sends a oh I did not
know that Sunday like version of me out
there that's cool so Miami's asking is
the demo two hours a game play to level
15 so you can make it to level 15 but
the type of looter shooter this game is
two hours is it's hard to say how much
content there is because so like the
tyrant mines is about a 45-minute strike
style mission me it can be faster I
think it depends on your group but yeah
it can take up to four all of that guy's
dead again so there is a level 15 cap
but we've seen gear drop up to about 19
so far yep and this game is intended to
be played kind of like Mass Effect's
co-op where you keep doing the same
content on harder and harder
difficulties although you can only go up
to hard in the 30
to the whatever the I figured what the
next one's called so I don't think I can
put a number of hours on it
it's just kind of like you can get to 15
and play until you're bored or you don't
get bored I did honestly I played it for
two days over VIP demo and I I was
itching to go again when it closed so
yeah I'm so far enjoying it now a crime
has been asking a bunch of out the end
game in the chat thanks for that
question crime I am gonna give an answer
that say might disagree with me on but I
don't care to be honest I just I like
honestly I'm kind of over games oh so
like we played a bunch of division by
the way and we have an embargo coming up
soon and division one I think was a game
that tried to make an end game and made
a much worse core game because of the
experience so I would rather that anthem
just make a good game and worry about
the end game later this is my personal
opinion but if you're chasing that sweet
end game I don't know man like they they
haven't given in any very clear answers
beyond the world is gonna change and I
think they've been looking at what four
nights been doing but we haven't seen it
so I don't know if it's there or if it's
gonna be there in like three months to
be honest like the division guys have
been division two guys have been talking
about endgame non-stop since the first
you know press event we went to it's
clearly on their minds I get the
impression anthem is just gonna try and
get out the door with the best game
possible up front and figure it out
later
that's just why pretty good all right
we're going in yeah that's my take from
from developer interviews that we've
done so far and press events we've been
to I don't know what do you guys think
you guys you guys want an end game up
front is that is that you know big on
your mind any improvements good over the
VIP demos is Kevin I don't think it's in
this version of the game
but they said for the final build you
will be able to run in for tarsus which
is a huge quality of life thing oh boy
slowly walking in for Tarsus
was not great not the business the funny
thing is if you look down it's like your
character actually is like jogging but
clearly like is not representative can I
stay in here probably not the Keene CEO
is asking about lead box Adam and
there's only cosmetics right that in
terms of like microtransaction II stuff
there's microtransaction stuff have we
oh I don't remember opening that one
screenshot that was I don't know leaked
or something on reddit recently that had
$20 skins wouldn't bothers me but then
Bioware immediately responded said like
oh that that's like an old bill this is
something like we're constantly evolving
and changing and you know working with
and in my head I was like you know what
as mad as people are and I'm not saying
I would ever spend $20.00 of skin but
that's just following the fortnight
model however yeah the skins I saw we're
not that cool they're not like fortnight
we're like you look completely different
so $49 is a lot for tonight the the $20
skins in for tonight are they put some
love into those skins like honestly I
think the the ones that you can buy for
$20 tend to be like kind of above and
beyond the rest like the ice dragon and
somebody pointed out for tonight also
has a lot of detail and their stuff so
there's like a lighter hammer it has
like a lighter on the end of it and the
lighter I just also read it this morning
the lighter doesn't cast a shadow
because in real life like flames don't
cast a lot of new players our new
javelin pilots today it looks like what
11 I was wondering why there are so many
Rangers but Rangers as you have
mentioned still pretty good starting
class they're the best class versus
single enemies we did get some responses
people I mean there are people who
really do want to want the end game hey
I think you're like that day I mean what
did what do you want out of this game I
mean I definitely ooh a shotgun level 19
I definitely want like I don't want to
just like necessarily repeat content but
maybe at the same time in my head I'm
saying that now because I'm just so used
to destiny but like considering I played
so much Diablo it kind of makes sense
if they have just like higher difficulty
but just depends on how much stuff there
is to do because at some point like I
kind of got tired of killing that spider
over and over even though like I know
I'm doing it to get loot and you're
getting loot for other javelins but I
just need variation and I mean maybe
there's enough world events maybe
there's a world event every two weeks or
a week or something that maybe that's
enough to kind of like get you to come
back I also like in terms of the endgame
I'm also curious of some of the highest
tier like weaponry like how or like even
abilities like how does that affect
gameplay you like when you get Jara's
wrath finally yeah but like what is it
just an assault rifle that has some
special like I don't know cuz like
weapons the way they are right now is
like you have these extra perks right
like all right mine has plus 20 spare
ammo and 10 fire rate that's not bad
that's pretty good right you're
basically chasing like rolls that's
already more than destiny does yes and
no I mean you have like outlaw kill clip
stuff like that you're still chasing for
that right so if Jara's wrath as a
exotic or whatever highest here they're
calling it right it doesn't is just kind
of like this but like has like five
perks and the perks are just like fire
rates spare ammo and something else and
it's only in name and maybe having one
extra perk that's not that enticing to
me like if chars wrath itself has like a
your bullets every now and then will
explode or something whereas this other
assault rifle can't do that then that
seems pretty cool to me right it seems
like there's an elemental system under
the hood which destiny one did but then
sort of got away from you know like
destiny 1 shields enemy shields mattered
a lot more and it feels like there's
from us playing tyrant mines and this
one it seems like the spiders are likely
more susceptible to fire and less
susceptible to acid so there there might
be systems in play here where there will
be missions that you will need to have
certain elemental builds on I have a
feeling it's gonna go in that direction
more classic RPG ish yeah to the chat we
were talking about for Knight simply
because we were comparing
the the skins monetization model yeah i
the the screenshot that came out was
twenty dollars roughly but i don't think
that'll be necessarily the case at the
end but you just you just never know did
you want to give it a run yeah i would
go for it oh can you play for a while
I'll talk to the chat I'm gonna have to
duck out at twelve
um but I'm actually we're really curious
about this class we've we played all the
other classes so far except for
interceptor the currency is way
different why are you comparing it well
because unless I'm mistaken the the
screenshot that was out of the the how
much it costed by skin with shards which
is like I think the currency you would
pay for is the equivalent twenty dollars
and so like I was just saying how twenty
dollars doesn't seem insane when you
compare it to like fortnight which is
twenty dollars forth like the good skin
and to be fair and fortnight you can't
just buy a 20 dollar chunk of change
you have to buy you know they they
always make you buy a little bit more
then what something actually costs so
you don't have to buy skins I mean to me
it's it's all that it like that's the
good thing and I hope that that's how it
continues like anything that's micro
transaction based is just aesthetics
like I don't that's fine like if you
want to go and make your Ranger look
different than wine whatever I there's
enough in-game options that I can like
do what I want and make my guy look like
war machine and feel fine about it you
know when we were at a when we were at
an event over at EA I actually got to
talk talking to one of the reps about
the fiasco of Battlefront 2 and like off
the record he was like pretty
he was pretty like broken up about it
because they really screwed that one up
and like there was a huge backlash and I
get the impression that they are scared
about that stuff right now so if they
work in loot boxes power bettin man and
this is just an opinion I don't think so
man it'll be way later if they ever do
it Jim Masterson for Knight is
free-to-play though this is an important
decision yes that's true but what I'm
just saying is that like it's just
aesthetics right like so it's not that
as big of a deal because it doesn't
influence gameplay it doesn't up
hello you know it's interesting pass
tired immunity that's why um so $20 is a
disgusting price comment in the chat I
thought that it was in and I've run into
people at these events who like have
friends who are the whales those are the
people who just buy everything from
these game yeah there are people who
like just play one game and they don't
really care and they can buy everything
there they're the reason why skins are
$20 because somebody buys them I mean if
people didn't buy $20 skins they
wouldn't be yeah dollars still caiaphas
says that they showed off in the dev
stream that the higher end loot will
have those more developed perks such as
kills with your rockets refresh trick or
nade and make it explode into cluster
grenades that kind of stuff yeah but
there's a weapon itself have interesting
properties other than like influencing
other like skills
I guess because that to me like that's
almost more like division desk than in
some degree so it doesn't have like a
special kind of like or whatever or like
it's harder to make them feel different
on a third-person shooter those guys are
gross little tongues we are playing on
PC right now by the way and using a pad
we got in just fine yeah first try no
problem I will say interceptors got the
cool little flip that no one else has I
also feel like yeah maybe your comment
about it being like pretty tanky is kind
of accurate just because I don't know I
feel like I've been able to go in a
decent amount depending on what we're
fighting without feeling that scared I
guess it feels like the class names
don't give you a very good idea of what
they do that's something you're just
gonna have to figure out I kind of like
treated or thought this class would be
more assassin based and like heavy
damage kind of like I don't know and it
kind of is go bomb says does this game
have a healer the closest thing we've
seen so far is the storms ability to
shield and robot to shield I go to a
Rangers got shield to he's actually got
a almost better shield in a way you
could argue because it's like a Titan
bubble oh yeah there's certainly ways to
create space for you to revive people
and
don't think we've seen any abilities yet
that straight-up heal but we're I don't
know it feels like we're very early in
this game
I agree crying they probably leaked it
on purpose just to see how people would
feel and now they know that $20 is too
much because every youtuber has made a
video that's like no you can't do this
man if they haven't won in that lesson
already they paying attention sag 1432
says is this game fun playing solo uh I
think so I think you could get through
it solo like I I matched me the whole
time almost I played sometimes with you
guys I think that I would I would have
personally more fun playing with people
I knew just because we could combo
things more you just have that open line
of communication and I'm not saying that
you wouldn't necessarily get that line
of communication here too but obviously
it's different when you play these
multiplayer games with people you know
we played both together and I think
we've all done some random matchmaking
in the VIP demo and obviously it's more
fun with friends but it felt fine
although I will say there was one puzzle
that we couldn't figure out with randoms
it was that uh that bridge puzzle where
you had to get all the glyphs to do
something yeah so they're actually the
clues are actually like in some cases
under the walk oh jeez under the walkway
of like where the glyph was or like
above like you just had to find the
hints and actually the answers are all
out there now of course but they're
there here's the problem when when
you're randomly match-made with people
everybody's going around and trying to
solve the puzzle yeah like their own way
their own way which means that it's an
almost impossible to get done because
everybody's flipping the glyphs and the
glyphs need to be in a certain order I
agree with that so I would say mixed
like some of the puzzles but you know
there's actually answering that question
is two ways one some of the puzzles I
think are too complicated for random
matchmaking and some of the enemies like
this enemy here is not great for certain
builds if you were playing just by
yourself
they shouldn't have blew their load
there okay like the Colossus will have a
really hard time on a specific point I
think in this mission yeah the next boss
part like when I was playing Colossus I
was like this kind of sucks so there's
no minions to farm and the Colossus
doesn't regen health and there's four
bosses we
is the most anti Colossus room you could
possibly cook up it's out three Titans
right I think it's four three three okay
yeah but it's still annoying because I
do the wave thing and you're just kind
of like a clunky you kind of jump okay
but you're not jumping that great I mean
like I think if you get used to it it's
fine like at some point I got used to it
and like you can kind of like chill on
the platforms and a sort of other brute
go bong I would argue that the Colossus
is mislabeled it's it's a berserker it's
not a tank it doesn't regen how well
that we know of
yes like you don't know like I haven't
we have not seen the it's like the all
the abilities yet like it definitely
pulls aggro you can if you use the like
one war shout or whatever does the last
thing I would do is that class is pull
aggro you do not want to pull fire the
one I had was I did the one where
everyone takes 33% less damage or
something so yeah there's three theres
gonna be one like here so we'll lower
alt to kill it well actually I don't
even know if the alts gonna kill them
right off the bat because he might be
immune Kiki no the best way to get the
demo in PC is to just do Origen access
which ain't too expensive and you can
cancel it after a month if you're not
interested in it the man's not taking
damage yet there he goes
see you could not do this as Colossus he
would have been dead yeah back you are
definitely I I'm just gonna call it the
Interceptor is the tank
Crump saying I'm actually sad there's no
pvp plans imagine this with PvP
mechanics on a well-designed map it'd be
interesting
you know Mass Effect again like people
keep comparing this to other games but
honestly to me this is just exactly Mass
Effect co-op plus Mass Effect it's like
an in-between of those two games Mass
Effect
never had PvP and I don't think these
systems were designed for PvP but it
would be interesting to see how this
would work in a PvP arena I it would be
a good luck maybe PvP ve like the dark
zones I don't think it would be very
good pure PvP 808 G says chaotic mess
skipping this it is your right to do so
what game are you gonna play you know
are you thinking about division - just
out of curiosity are you sticking with
destiny or if you are not playing anthem
what is it that you guys are thinking
about in a sort of the February March
timeframe oh I did not necessarily can
you cross play good question I don't
think there's cross play but every every
game should be cross playing by now oh I
almost feel like cross play will be like
next gen I mean there's some already
because like Rocky we can hold gosh
cross plays apparently not too crazy to
do at least according to the rocket
League devs
in fortnight also apparently saying it's
not too crazy to do it's just more of a
business you got to get a bunch of
competing businesses to agree to play
with each other
like feel like I did nothing SEC says
he'll be playing Metro and Far Cry yes
that February is a crazy month we we we
already got hands-on with Far Cry new
dawn and as a big fan of Far Cry 5 I
actually liked it quite a lot although
it has some RPGs and some like rougher
RPG systems in it that you will you'll
have to like it's more Borderlands style
you shoot people and numbers pop out of
their heads and you need to craft
weapons that are high enough level to
kill them in Far Cry new dawn so if you
like Borderlands in Far Cry it's a good
mix of those two games and a lot of
people are excited for Metro we also
have a preview of Metro and Far Cry
phone game spot yep um we're probably
playing this I I don't know kind of
wanna play jump force but I have a
feeling that'll be like a one day it was
fun I saw my anime buddies and called it
a day yeah I don't really think I did
much there I don't feel like I deserve
to marry medallions I like barely did
any damage to the boss also we had a
colossus this has got to be a bug I was
just with the Colossus these are the
people I played with the first time but
whatever there there's plenty of bugs
and also okay you never know what build
of the game you're getting in a demo
usually demos are not finished yet I
want to see like another class I can
play something else wrote thinks not
really happy with what they did with
Metro is that because of the open-world
aspects of it ex core one says I'm
really hoping that there's a possibility
to do a full support build on at least
one javelin I am getting a support I'm
generally a support player but so far I
don't see that happening well it depends
right like you could potentially run
well not like a traditional support in
the sense that like you can heal your
teammates and things like that but like
I'm sure you could potentially make like
a support storm or something maybe you
just run a lot of ice element and you're
just like disabling a lot of enemies and
then your teammates are then following
up damage and comboing off that
because like the ice shard when I
watched you play last time we streamed
like it came back pretty quickly and
that's with you not even really
customizing your character yet to even
dude like have that regen even faster
and then you know you could do that to
two turrets because you have like ten
shards right and you still have that
wall which blocks incoming damage and
then you can do damage that's a good
point actually both even storm sure yeah
the storm both the storm and the
Colossus great with storm but you can
actually try it out
use their abilities primarily they don't
even necessarily I think as a Colossus I
rarely ever went to my gun actually was
just using the flame throwing a shot
coil and the shield to and like almost
never shot with a weapon and the
Interceptor I started the storm is the
same you can get by as kind of being the
space wizard and you can almost
exclusively just use your abilities and
never never need your gun or rarely need
your gun which is kind of cool so you
know it's a little bit unfortunate is
that because I switched out my skill I
think there's a focus seal I think you
start off with the ice shards it's
either this one or support or the blast
seal but for whatever reason you can't
get that one back and you can't craft
any right now so like it comes default
but now that I have equipped other ones
where you blow it up no I didn't blow it
up it's just once you like use something
else it's gone interesting so yeah it's
kind of unfortunate we're never gonna go
in so we'll just be farther you know I
do have one one criticism that's been
bugging me
and it's that and I've heard this echoed
by other people and also in the chat
when loot drops currently in this game
and when you earn loot there isn't a
satisfying enough sound effect mmm like
I would like the game to really let me
know that something is special with
sound design that makes you feel extra
good when that happens and it seems like
a lot of the things you earn in this
game is it's like understated when you
get something it's less exciting yeah
free open demo right now and if you like
I said the here's what I did with
battlefield 5 I just
did the origin super accessing for 15
bucks and played it for a month and then
if you don't like it cancel same with
anthem if you want to just start anthem
on the 15th pay the 15 bucks and then
cancel at the end of the month if you
feel like you got your money's worth
it's a good way to do it I mean if you
guys want to try it this is the weekend
it's the open demo so I heard Xbox is
having problems logging in right now but
I think ps4 should be fine PC is fine
you know so go check it out see how you
like it see how it feels for you you're
gonna have to start off with a ranger
and then eventually when you hit level
12 you unlock another javelin not sure
if at 15 you'll get you know all the
javelins that's what happened to us last
weekend it was the end of last weekend
yeah but yeah there will be a sound
effect according to kite this he says
confirmed via Twitter Leslie said the
hub is more empty than my wallets um
that's legit it's a little bit weird
that there isn't a tower here yes yeah
there will be one at the end of the game
we don't know how long the campaign is
it could be 10 hours it could be 40
hours like division two's got a 40-hour
campaign I doubt it'll be that long GT
to get new javelins if you're just
starting get to level 12 you'll you'll
then be able to choose one other javelin
to unlock so pick wisely and as
mentioned last week Sunday they
eventually just unlock them all for
everyone so there's there's that by the
way also we have not run into the
loading the 95 percent loading bug yet
but last weekend in the VIP demo if your
screen gets stuck at 95% loading quit
the game and go back in and there's a
cool resume feature that'll just get you
right back into yep you can tell like
almost like immediately that it's like
frozen there's a triangle there's a
specific triangle and if it gets stuck
halfway through that triangle on the
right side of your screen you're boned
it's like if you're like 98 percent
you're pretty much screwed if it's not
moving Bobby says don't buy the game if
you don't like loot sounds well it's
it's not nothing anyway so yeah it's not
enough for me to not play the game but
it is something that they could do
better
zippy I believe I install down then on
the normal like just a SATA hard drive
not not our SSD loading times are bad
sweet baby James seventy-eights
talking about loading times I'm not
gonna lie like of all the things that
they could immediately
improve on this game loading screens are
out of control sometimes you'll end a
mission go to a loading screen then go
to your end of round summary then go to
another loading screen then go to four
Tarsus then go to another loading screen
to customize your build it's out of
control seriously and they really need
to do something more like destiny or
like this I think I think we're gonna
get one here yeah right there there's a
loading to get one right here like if
there's one thing that's really
bothering me about this game they could
have at least maybe found like a cooler
way to do a loading screen at least kind
of fake it a little bit or something but
this is straight up like it breaks you
out of the game or you you got to do the
Destiny thing where you can just go to
your loadout whenever you want oh you
mean like just pull up your inventory
yeah like when you're waiting you know
like destiny does the ships flying which
is at least a little bit better and then
you can pull up your your inventory
anytime you want yeah just so people
know I was able to play on my really old
6 7 year-old PC the only good thing in
it is like a 980 but everything else
it's like an i5 with like I don't know 8
gigs of RAM or something something
terrible so it's doable but my PC
sounded like it was like a airplane
ready to take off though and my CPU was
going like a hundred percent when I was
playing but I never had any like latency
issues though so everyone's saying it's
a little weird to have those extremely
advanced mechs yet they have to use guns
um yeah we're talking about this a bit
earlier but at least two of the classes
don't have to use their guns at all the
Colossus can go purely on abilities like
shock oil and flamethrower and the storm
can also go almost purely on abilities
yeah and that's like not even like
really customizing a build yet either
right so that ability is so cool it
bounces between like two people if
they're close enough this is the room we
were talking about earlier so I think
this room is a little bit too
complicated for random matchmaking
because it's because of the other
players potentially kind of like ruining
it for you right yeah like everybody's
if everybody tries to solve the puzzle
at the same time like why are these guys
dying so fast got a bunch of 15 well if
they're not a ranger they're probably at
15
yeah but still they we're playing on
hard okay so let me show you what I mean
by like the glyph answers are in the
room like this one is like right under
well actually they got to go activate it
first sorry my bad already like we will
not be buying a twenty dollar javelin
skin nor will I ever to be honest I will
if chat tells us to do it
you're welcome Marvin glad you uh you're
able to play the demo now are you all
play on a mission yeah we're just quick
playing missions we could do strongholds
in a little bit this is the stronghold
you said you've cleared it faster but
the stronghold can can be yeah I'm just
saying it can be like oh is that the
purple one yeah okay so like in this
case like the answer is like right there
right that's one of them and then the
other one these guys have clearly played
also like I said the answers are all out
there the honest answers don't touch
anything here
see this is the yellow right there okay
and then the red is somewhere over here
it's like it's also like above or like
something here there's definitely oh
there it is see so it's there but like
you said I do agree that like with
people just like trying like your
instinct is to just go hit the tablet or
the glyph and be like oh it changes to
four different things but at some point
you in your head it's like oh there's
got me an answer somewhere so but the
problem is everybody's simultaneously
trying to solve it and they're all
getting the wrong answer on different
glyphs I've had that I have like oh this
one's purple for sure I know that I did
change the purple and then go to the
next one then change it and someone else
is like totally my purple one I'm like
no that's the answer man maybe it should
just a simple solution would be for it
to just lock in there's no way that's
true goober true bird if you have a two
thousand dollar PC on low you should be
able to play cuz I played it on my jank
low and like my or my really jank system
and like assignment $2,000 it wasn't
like as good of an experience as I'm
having right now but it definitely was
playable ticks asking can you get any
legendary weapons yes we've seen 19 what
do they call rare where it's everybody's
like still used only yeah you're only
getting Blues as the highest tier right
now
I think even in the difficulty prompt it
states that if your level 30 and you're
trying to do like that first that next
tier of difficulty you need to be at
least epic
so I'm guessing Purple's epic we need to
get our destiny translator on like
what's exotic it's probably like epic
legendary and then exotic yeah maybe
ancient I don't know
so that was storm even though my
character there shows as a wow that was
like a terrible mission to get loot from
hmm oh you know what's interesting
actually so the I think gamble is
talking about this so if you go into
free room you don't actually get XP just
from killing things you get XP from
doing from using the system's right so
from combos and things like that
clearing objectives and combos but you
can't just farm minions for XP which is
interesting it encourages people to
actually engage the game and the best in
the best way as opposed to just loot
caving it which is yeah I was trying to
get to the next level and I was just
killing stuff in free-to-play and then I
realized oh that's not gonna work it
works if you're doing combos and things
like that if you're engaging the systems
of the game yeah um also Leslie there is
you can't buy a legendary weapon that's
not how it works there's only a like -
everything that we know is that it's all
cosmetic I don't think we got any
upgrades which is unfortunate some
comments about how the game looks
honestly the environments are gorgeous
and the javelins are good-looking
animations are solid I think like from a
visual perspective I got no complaints
with this game I think it looks real
good except for some of the eyes are
dead inside which is a thing in video
games does the other guy want to play I
don't know do you want to fight you'd
have to invert it that's fine we're
gonna uninvite it after you're in a
storm though did you want to play
interceptor oh you could switch at the
Ford right now sure play some storm this
cable is kind of short though you should
be fine yeah so I'll take over chat
thanks guys and gals for coming tuning
into GameSpot live we're checking out
the anthem open beta meaning if you're
at home and you want to try it out
before you decide on potentially
purchasing it you know I would oh you
wanna play storm
alright I'm just looking for the invert
Oh gotcha yeah you might have to back
all the way out okay so actually you
know here's one thing if you're just
playing this now you get used to this
but it's a little bit weird when you do
a mission this many is kind of
convoluted so you have to actually click
in then you have to pick the mission you
want to do then you have to back out
then you have to pick the difficulty and
we always have the difficulty set but
the thing about your attachments are
either hit start or you can hit launch
yeah but I would not free play so far I
didn't see anything that interesting and
free play except there was one time when
there was these two monsters that I was
like cheesing on a cliff because they
couldn't hit me but then eventually like
I don't know the game like figured it
out or something and it like kicked me
or whatever where's the where's the
control flip actually don't right bumper
all the way across maybe you have to be
in a mission to actually do it there's a
I will say the menus are kind of
convoluted like crazy there you go
there we go this is how you quit the
game you have to actually go all the way
to settings you mean you don't hit alt
f4 like I do yeah that's a thing place
storm please I played it and it's
awesome Wow I just played storm and
Aaron hasn't played interceptor I'll
probably be on for a bit so I can always
switch back to storm Marvin if you're
gonna stick around we'll probably check
out Colossus too at some point I played
mainly Colossus during my first weekend
The Hub looks so sparsely populated that
no one lives there any reason why I mean
there's a fair amount of NPC's in the
for Tarsus so you can talk to a fair
amount of them and then you have like
two dialogue option prompts I don't know
if that'll have any like meaning down
the road maybe this is what a was
talking about so you can like still you
can see laughs you look like you're
joggin but then and like this gave me
the placebo effect yeah that I was like
yeah I'm running and I feel like I'm
going faster than this yeah but I don't
know if that's the case it would be
funny if it was the case they are gonna
increase running speed for the final
build they took that fee yeah yeah oh
also sorry to cut you off
I think this build is like the e3 it's
like it's older is what someone in chat
had mentioned previously so you know I'm
sure there's gonna be some changes do
you want to do free play or I would pick
a mission or the stronghold in all
honesty
only because I don't know I didn't like
free play from what I've seen so far is
like it's good for farming materials
like that like I was getting a lot more
embers and things like that via free
play then I was kind of like doing
missions and stuff there was like way
more things to harvest
I hope the free play stuff gets a little
bit more interesting they almost need
and this is because we played so much
destiny they almost need public event
type stuff to happen more often on these
free play areas on the map because yeah
devolution kind of just like every now
and then it's like oh there's like a
rift II thing that's spawning guys and
then kill them and then that's kind of
it like but hands down this game would
be better if it was more like if the
free room was more like destiny they
should have like 16 people running
around in the free room area but you
never know like you said there's like
there's an something that's gonna happen
Sunday like maybe that's in free play
that like I did some flickin event maybe
I don't know maybe they'll give you a
taste of because like what did they
oh so you're gonna play some cool you
had said to me I think I think it was
you or maybe Rob or someone had said
like oh like they want to try to do it
like fortnight style like where the map
changes and there's like cataclysms and
you know environmental changes and
things like that I'm curious if they're
gonna do any of that Sunday maybe not
maybe they're just gonna do something
like in the free play area but so this
is the people asked earlier about
support classes so that's the shield
that will help you revive people
unfortunately I don't have any support
abilities that one kind of like fire
between enemies and that's just an orb
that that's a lightning orb sadly I got
rid of my ice shards and I really should
have did that what's up fire scorpion
how are you what's up team oh yeah Ben
also agrees to few public events yeah
there just doesn't feel like there's
that much going on with the this feels
like we got matched me with the free
plate we're in the we're in the
stronghold and your guys are missing one
of the relics to trigger the next thing
so just look around for like a glowy orb
thing and if you can find it so then you
just bring it back to that black area
and then usually you have a radar that
tells you where it is the seems bugged
see you anything you think on radar I
think we got matched into a bug mission
actually I don't know because I've never
actually looked for it that way I
usually just run into him on accident or
as I'm like searching around I'll see
one just hanging on the ground it's
usually like a little black crystal
that's glowing or an echo actually is
what they're called here I'll back out
in a sec if nothing starts happening oh
there you go there it is there's
something on the map and that could also
just be a resource there's definitely
some resources systems in this game
there is back there maybe back in the
corner it was I don't know if that's
just a cave being to the other side oh
no it's just a cave kind of glowing cave
glowy bits that's weird I think we
definitely did get the prompt over here
resource I'm gonna keep reading chat
rather just get em k-11 guys yeah but
the thing is MK 11 is April so I got I
got some time to play anthem before you
know we get there I'm gonna back out in
the first storm on Sunday the area zero
says I don't think so I don't know my
guess is either
what are they Titans like a Titan
invasion or maybe a environmental change
yes we don't know what's gonna happen on
Sunday they've been teasing some special
event on Sunday that was not in the VIP
demo yeah as Bobby Simmons dimensions
they're gonna have an area that will be
populated with other javelins it'll be
the launch Bay it's something you get
was it like posts kind of like the
single like campaign issue it's probably
the same thing I mean Vegas level based
so we're aware that it that later in the
game there is a social space they also
talked about having the the launch Bay
for you to go back in between missions
with your friends I we don't know if
they're the same thing or if that's a
new thing but a social space would be
better than just kind of random
storyline so I think a couple people
have asked us like hey what javelins
your favorite or like what are you gonna
mein
I think it's gonna be tough for me to
tell right away I've only played the
before like sparsely I've mainly played
Ranger and Colossus I also don't know
what those javelins look like endgame or
like with all the other abilities and I
think I'll be more enticed by what
abilities I get I guess and also just
like what everyone else is playing cuz
you want to have a solid team right or
you know seems like this right now this
storm is the crowd favorite just because
it has the largest variety of abilities
hmm let's try this again
I think that I couldn't have enjoyed the
amount of Java when I played earlier it
felt better than playing Colossus I know
I've never enjoyed the like really tanky
tanky characters I kind of like that
in-between not too glassy but not too
tanky so I'll probably end up playing
like interceptor or storm maybe Ranger
if Ranger really like you said is one of
the highest dps to like a single target
I wouldn't be shocked if there's like
one Ranger like in a group of four I say
Phil I think a snow sorry Pete excuse me
Pete Hill asked are the service better
this week I think so and they must be
because one knock on wood but we haven't
had the loading bug error not yet we got
in first try where it is on PC which was
a nightmare last weekend we couldn't
even get in on Friday we had to switch
to ps4 to play I mean they had a legit
server problem that they say they've
resolved it they fixed it mainly by
Saturday I feel like Friday was a kind
of a [ __ ] show but although Saturday you
would still get the 95 percent load
freeze yeah turtle assassin acid what do
you think about the three other
difficulties that come after hard how
will they change up gameplay well for
sure that all your enemies are gonna do
more damage and have more health I'm not
sure unless you know more about it that
in terms of like it does that changed
gameplay mechanics at all other than
what I just mentioned what it feels like
is they're gonna mess with elemental
resistances so Oh
for example the spiders seem to be
resistant they seem to be very
susceptible to spider but resistant to
acid you just said the spider is
resistant to spider sorry
acid okay
it's better resistant to acid and
susceptible to fire there you go
Saturday was still buggy cars oh really
maybe I just didn't play as much
Saturday I feel like it wasn't that bad
see like this is when you want the ice
like icing the turrets is so good also I
just saw like interceptors go up to that
thing and melee the crap out
interceptors yeah yeah I think
interceptors are the tank all right I
gotta get used to whatever build you
have here I have a marksman rifle scout
or a scout rifle and a pistol or no I I
might have gave you this sniper I can't
recall sorry nope got big bads right
here so I what I was doing before what
this class was that one will jump on
going nice so I actually think this this
ability is pretty good the lbu one the
fire one because it keeps them on fire
and I'm guessing you could probably
combo off that pretty easily and that
ability jumps between enemies so we'll
try doing cops you ready got guys down
see if this combos now the other one
doesn't come up quite as fast yeah see
the Colossus probably went in thinking
like I can Yolo in there Colossus really
can't Colossus is not a tank just full
full warning it's not a tank it's it's
misleading we actually think that the
tank badge we actually took us half the
demo to figure out we could dodge before
hey hey that was you not me dude I will
throw you under the bus right now
alright fine I'll take it because even
the Rangers kind of got us like a circle
- kind of thing whoa that bounced off
the rock that's pretty cool
alright so I would like here let me see
if I can I think I've take care of that
guy before I can revive my guess is that
these guys might not have done this too
much yet because you really need to
focus on those turrets the dudes
actually like just wreck I'm gonna get a
wall up OOP
let me get a wall up and try and revive
nope didn't get a quite in time I think
those guys are insane the elites that
kind of like do the rapid-fire
like have the machine guns it it does so
much damage so sorry good no
that'sthat's it the stock class for
interceptor
I'm sorry for storm has a like a nice
attack that I think is really useful
just because it freezes enemies yeah
which we I swapped out well because
tenability and I was like oh that that
sounds cool
honestly the level is not as important
as your ability to set up combos
I think the combos are really the
powerful part there's your like insane
guy out there they just hover and then
drop if you get hit by all his machine
gun bullets it feels like getting take
off half health at least on hard can you
download that demo to the PS store yes
you can King Josh well I actually did it
yesterday but you should be able to find
it it's a little bit difficult to find
at least yesterday for preload I had to
search for it I think and then
eventually I found anthem demo so take a
look take a take a look through the the
store and you'll find it though it's
definitely there though I think we're
having the new players playing Colossus
think it's tank that's good stuff I mean
even the shield doesn't really absorb
that much and if you do lose the shield
you're pretty boned like you you pretty
much have to hide or find as you had
mentioned you if you have the
flamethrower lightning coil you want to
find all those little mobs that you can
easily kill and then you'll get that HP
back and that's kind of how you do it
it's farm mobs Colossus is farm mods and
then super that's super on the boss
that's how that class works I actually
would use a sniper because the sniper
does like 9,000 to those turrets that's
okay no the switch weapon button is a
bit weird this whole square it's because
there's no other button left all right
so we got taking these turrets okay
doesn't bounce
I got no ammo yeah you do you got to
hold it down so the sniper is you have
to hold all the way down and then really
oh it's like there you go it's like a
fusion rifle yep interesting okay got my
shield wall up team took care of that
and that's how they kind of balance it a
bit is like the fact that you have to
charge it and it's a single shot each
time that feels good okay yeah now we're
talking
okay so that kind of goes off there's
quite a bit to the boss on this level
the spider once you hit the crit spots I
think it does like 9,000 something for
the crit spots so this is a bit more you
gotta aim just know that you can only
have like around six bullets depending
on if you have like more ammo on your
like armor and stuff like that or
components rather sorry I like II hope
I'm getting surrounded you're fine
yeah let's do an attack for fun how
about this really I'm just doing it cuz
iron that's fair I suppose I wouldn't
like to see you do it on a turret but
I'm not playing so I'm not gonna
backseat Drive that flamethrower though
red Xs PvP will give this game life
after the story and repetitive and game
content potentially getting boring I
think it's gonna be tough I don't I
don't think they have any plans for it
I'm curious what their answer to so they
they didn't really openly say they'll
have raids but they're gonna have like
content that is in that I don't know in
that tier or vein so I want to know what
that is I guess so that should combo if
it gets him at the same time alright
we're good tanks already down yeah no
he's not a tank Aaron sorry to preserve
our preserved yes yeah the losses he's a
piece of Berserker I had played almost
exclusively as a card see he knows
what's up though he's got the he's got
the flamethrower which is a very strong
ability and it's like I think you have
like almost like a hundred or something
okay did that combo no did not combo
alright so yeah you really do you have
to think about your combos yeah and it's
it's a little difficult there's there's
a there's a good amount of abilities I
haven't played with all of them I know
that like up team the ice one combo into
the the lightning the two stock ones
that you had yeah like they combo they
did and we don't have combo anymore so
that's less awesome a funnier than me
yeah man says yeah I could care less
roof UV there are people like that I
played PvP and destiny and I enjoyed it
but like PvE was definitely where I was
so I don't necessarily mind an all PvE
game I mean I played Diablo for so long
even though technically that should have
had PvP too but if there's good enough
loot to kind of like chase after and
that that loot feels good to use and
it's special then I'm sure I'll be
playing for a while but again like Aaron
I think Aaron had mentioned a while ago
like he can play this game for you know
40 hours and just be okay with it and
not have to like keep playing yeah I'm
I'm not too obsessed with any game at
this point
um I think endgame I know everybody's
chasing destiny and I think it's made a
lot of games worse than they would have
been on otherwise Daniel II Barras curve
bring up a point like the bigger
question for for him is you know the
frequency of added content and is the
cadence high enough and if it is then
it'll work but if it isn't then you know
and I agree it's you know even though we
call them chores and destiny you know
Tuesday was a reset day and you knew you
had new stuff to do away from a shield
and to accomplish and and ways to get
loot so I am curious with anthem if we
will also kind of get enough and I don't
want to be the guy that says like
drip-feed content but you know what I
mean like there's that there's enough
stuff to keep us going and we're not
just farming these same strongholds over
and over that wall is actually not that
true yeah it's really not that strong of
a wall well to be fair I think in
laurits made of wind so but it doesn't
there's another class that has a bubble
so yeah the Ranger I will say the flying
just feels real good in this game except
for when I run into a wall but that's on
me I guess Oh WTF this is GameSpot and
IGN well welcome to GameSpot calm if you
were playing Colossus like I can't just
back off now you you can't do that
because you don't regen health uh yeah I
mean you're basically going in farming
those lower end guys helping take the
shield's off at these guys like kind of
like helping set up for the rest of the
team is how I how I envisioned it
yeah like DC uh past that wind wall went
down for any sort of heavy enemies I I'm
sure that there will be a way to upgrade
that later on yeah we could also be just
not using it properly I haven't played
enough storm to like really know Oh use
it on the enforcer I don't know if it'll
hit he's pretty far away okay nice nice
combos big damage big deeps on those
three scarred all the spore I mean like
honestly I've been having a really good
time some of it is because this is this
is new some of it's because honestly I
really really loved Mass Effect's co-op
see if I'm taking fire you're good I
just watch out for the fire because
these guys are coming yeah I got my
dodge which the Colossus doesn't have
yeah his his dodge is the shield but you
can't shield smash and like kind of like
kind of like do a charging attack which
is pretty good stuff man I like this
fusion rifle I'm just gonna use destiny
terms for everything until I get used to
it and then chat will either love you or
hate you for it apparently as long as we
don't talk about fortnight they're good
I guess that's fair you should try to
see if you can use your fire thing to
have it bounce back and forth between
those two and maybe it'll help all right
which bumper there we got one so that
one should bounce back and forth maybe
get behind him yeah so uh I felt really
good like I was always afraid of those
guys with the three other classes but
like man with the Interceptor it feels
so good to just be nimble and get behind
him and like sling is a crit his like
tanker you know what's interesting is
when the Colossus has a flamethrower
they also have I don't think they get
credit but they also have those flame
tanks on their armor oh nice which is a
cool little touch I am looking for balls
it's hard to say stone ax I I haven't
seen enough of the rest of the game to
tell you like is that one like that yeah
to tell you oh there's a blue back there
although I don't even think if you left
it it would change anything do you pick
it up yeah I pick everything up in my
hand if I see it I'll pick it up but
like if not then it's kind of like
Microsoft
problem you see if I can get rid of that
for you I don't know I like oh sorry oh
is that really gonna stay there
you can take control um again I have to
alt-tab then Microsoft is uh there you
go can't tell you how many meetings just
if you work in an office hey Lise it's
not doing a Windows 10 update no you
gotta go turn that in you're the last
guy by the way where is it where's the
place we got turned in
well isn't it who's it not down there
it's a the arrow below you where's the
prompt the prompt sorry
well now in front of you oh it's all the
way up there where the rest of the crews
at where so it seems there we go
where yeah it's right below you it's
right below you behind you that big
circular platform we go BAM
sorry team we were dealing with
Microsoft yeah back to my original point
micrometers I have been hijacked by
Windows updates in this office are you'd
be surprised like how how little most
people even like update on their own
Microsoft don't give you an option
sometimes yeah they do
I think on some of my rigs I've turned
it off so that I have to do it myself
Microsoft you got a meeting yeah you got
an update
probably unloading whale although it's
funny that you're talking about the
prices of the I think the skins is what
you're talking about dropping when you
have whale in the name in your name
seems like there's definitely people who
are not super happy about the price of
skins it yeah
Bradshaw the open demos on all three
platforms so if your ps4 Xbox one you
can look for it in the store and get in
you'll obviously have your out okay
you're obviously going to have to gather
your turrets first
look for it and then download it first
before playing but yeah once you get in
you should be good oh you got one of
those amber or echo excuse me for later
we're a team
I don't leave that combo this is not a
great place to be and the mines and I'm
low on ammo you know uh you do run out
of ammo in this game quite a lot it's a
thing what am i team go that's probably
when the like they're both I think
that's probably when the certain weapons
that have spare ammo or they come
there's components that you can add to
have more ammo I believe so and then
even increase like your damage that
lightning ball doesn't seem that good
it's actually more just really not it's
really sensitive to bouncing off of the
environment so the ice the ice attack
that comes stock is really good at just
homing on targets this wall does not
hold up against anything heavy it's just
kind of like a minion wall although I'm
assuming you'll be able to upgrade it at
a later point
Jesus hit him
you know loadouts loadouts are really a
thing like there have been times where I
ducked out of a mission cuz I just
didn't have the right loadout which is
kind of cool like I like go like how
hard it is ducked out of it because I
just couldn't do it with the Lord out
that I had you have teammates though my
teammates weren't weren't really doing
all that great I will say I did not
enjoy my time when I was a colossus and
I think I wouldn't acid spray and like
something dumb asses prayed no good that
didn't feel good yeah that's it spray
did not feel good flamethrower is very
good the Lightning coil is very good the
railgun that comes stock is really good
it's like a mini sniper exactly like you
get to just use it so if their turrets
Daniel says don't forget I can spot your
shields recharge faster when hovering oh
okay cool
yeah there's a lot of like there's a lot
of subtle class differences ah dang it
the reload I'm not gonna get used to the
way that they swap buttons for reload in
melee you're gonna have to get used to
at some point because that's not
changing Sean Rodriguez yes except the
demo is an open demo so anyone can get
in if you had played last week on PC
here our progress carry don't carry it
over do you know if it carries over on
console as well it should carry over
just between just between ammo yeah
alright turret get stuffed
that's not sure I think you're hitting
the platform right in front of it
god dammit god dammit a I have a great
box we've been shocked surprisingly
there has not been an infinite load bug
yet so I don't know if they fixed it or
let's go home if we're just getting
lucky I would think that they might have
fixed it only because it's we've played
so many missions that it hasn't happened
yet whereas like there's by every other
time for me hold square the mail is just
gonna mess me up my muscle memory is to
not do that from so many different games
the muscle memory is there the thumb
stick so we're just to do why this log
yeah just to swap with why
I will say uh lose your to Colossus is
that what's going on here I think it
she's gone they bail on us I don't know
because I only see the Ranger up there
and I don't I really do like the blink
ability of the storm so VIP demo carries
over for console as well Thank You
Daniel
yeah I well I wasn't a hundred percent
sure it kind of makes sense though which
is cool so if you're lucky enough to be
on last Sunday and they when they
unlocked everything it was good yeah
unloading whale says okay I'm out see
you guys on xbox or ps4 or whatever's
thanks acting so thanks for coming by
unloading with ya have fun please come
back again when we should probably miss
for launch day or wal will do the like
origin access launch day which is like
the 15th which is a crazy day by the way
I don't know what we're gonna do like
all the plans for stream stuff maybe
we'll have some stuff early that we can
stream ahead of time whoa
today is this yeah like honestly if I
were playing solo I'd quit and I go back
and get an SMG and go back to the
there's no SMG that I know there is yeah
it's the Mass Effect SMG thing it looks
like a pistol but it's oh the the full
the machine gun pistol yeah okay it's
really an SMG I we got to do these
turrets guys who are there guys are my
Bros here you have silent crusader and I
think that's it like this might be
actually something we should quit out of
because we are down to dudes that's
interesting they should have they should
have the join like if someone else joins
a stronghold I would assume they would
get into this one with us hmm all right
turrets what are your thoughts on Ranger
as Dillon Gotham I think it's a solid
class I think he it's a it's almost like
an all-rounder in a way but again it's
so early to tell it felt good though and
I think the the Robin Farah like esque
super is like awesome so just find the
glowy bits and all you have one actually
so the Ranger does the most imp we were
talking about this earlier in the stream
and the Ranger does the most damage when
they detonate versus single targets so
they're really good against as
like when he combos is what you're
saying yeah detonating the primer
essentially so they're primers and
detonators in this game and it actually
works differently for every javelin the
Ranger does the most damage versus solo
targets the Colossus when they detonates
they have an area effect and then what
the interceptor in the storm are a
little bit more nuanced like one of them
spreads the damage or one of them
spreads the primer and the other one
spreads the element I think thank you
Mark Connors for the kind words love
watching these streams really helps in
understanding the game and how to play
thanks for stopping by again thanks for
your kind words
yeah great Fox no running yet my guess
is fry in the like in for tarsus yeah
not yet it's coming they definitely said
they're gonna do it watch out stuffs
gonna spawn alien shade let's be a
little bit more
I almost got smooth you didn't believe
me when I said stuff was gonna spawn I
did god I'm not gonna use to it I'm
sorry well there's no button you can
remap to unless you want to lose a
button so that's actually not true
there's a there's an alternate control
team okay what's so what's the
difference there but it's still not like
your classic it's - no your classic so
what does it do instead then it SWAT is
just get out no you go down fast
you're a storm yeah he's probably the it
storm Eswari the glasses of the floor
running it's harsh this yeah they've
confirmed they're gonna change that they
the explanation was Patrick no new
missions so far no new stronghold it's
the same beta as VIP as it stands but
they're supposed to be something on
Sunday something oh did you bet yeah
that was me I've played the shield
minion you're talking about the club no
it's because you guys died okay yeah so
that's just doing that part oh we have
to do it all over again so check this
out I don't there's only two of us
should we should we drop out and I mean
this is like this is a legit issue other
people might run into like if people
aren't doing quick play there's only two
of us and we're gonna do that I don't
think we can take the spider with two
people without that lasting 45 minutes I
talked to you you can do whatever you
want if you want
got new missions and said let's let's
let's mercy back out otherwise this is
just gonna be not fun you know we had a
question somebody asked about the
experience
yep that's total quit um I mean it's on
the map
somebody asked earlier about you know is
this a good solo experience so far it's
been good but like you know right now
we're stuck where the hell BL b1l are
just do lb once and then expedition okay
you know somebody asked us about the
solo experience so far I've had a really
good one but on the stream like this is
a good example where two people drop out
Oh
and W boom Oh says for Colossus you can
get components with up to a thousand HP
and 800 Armour yeah like I said it's
like in the build right now he took the
Colossus just doesn't feel like they
play that way but I will say I've only
gotten one like high level armor
component so I don't I haven't gotten to
but I could see it down the road being
tankier I just want it to feel more like
if it is supposed to be the tank class I
just wanted to feel more tanky and I
don't know what that is maybe making the
shield itself absorb a little bit more
damage just because you don't have a
Dodge I don't know it just doesn't feel
as tanky right now in this build but
this is again this is just this demo so
right now it's a it definitely feels
like a berserker class like it's there
for clearing minions and then using a
super on a boss but it's not there to
take heavy units it's more heavy units
are kind of more of a ranger thing I
feel like I could at least help with the
heavier units I don't know maybe that
was just with the flamethrower though I
don't know so because you don't
regenerate health you need to be
constantly waiting into minions and
picking up health as you combo and kill
them and obviously the best way to do
that in this demo is to combine
lightning coil or like the other leg
ability I'm gonna change the loadout for
sure
go for it you can even make your own
loadout if you want these guys real
quick did you say that we can't go back
to the original ability cuz you swap
maybe not you cannot get the shards back
that I know of because one you can't
craft it and two it's not even an option
anymore it's just not there did you run
the taunt ability or the mitigation one
I actually ran mitigation Daniel just
because again maybe I was playing the
Colossus wrong and that's very likely uh
but I felt like getting mitigation just
felt better like for the team and for
myself because then I could be a little
bit more aggressive with the Colossus in
doing kind of what you had mentioned
which is just like really getting in and
and killing all the smaller mobs just
you know clearing Ag agro sorry clearing
out all the minions and mobs so that
like you know a rest of the team could
just focus on killing the boss yes it
was really good for the the spider nest
area though like it like when when your
spider goes away and spawns all the
little minions like I was just
destroying the spiders that were coming
out of like the certain caves it was
also good for just rescuing people in
trouble
so here the fulcrum machine pistol this
is actually an SMG that's what that is
it says uncommon machine pistol and I
will not call these things not what they
are I can do that
machine I will I will not it acts like
an SMG okay wind wall so we can't change
that yeah Chris PAP I don't know about
that yet that's I don't know yet armor
look what we do here sniper rifle ammo
we could use that for that sniper rifle
ammo compartments we don't really need
hover more hover you were going more
armor I went more hover because I didn't
have that sniper one and I didn't think
that ammo one was that great I would
definitely keep the armor health one
though this guy yeah you got rid of it
on the other one there yeah like I feel
like I'm gonna spam six armor
enforcement's or something yeah
I don't that's not true because oh yeah
we got the ability sweet you got
lightning back okay lightning that was
way better and I don't know I still
liked that fire thing I think it's cool
it goes back and forth see you can't you
can't craft and you can't see you just
can't get it back I don't know why that
that's the case but that wasn't that in
your Devastator is a great sniper yeah
it's it's
really solid against the stronghold
spider boss if you hit the crit spots it
does like 9k okay let's try again you
gonna try Stockholm again yeah look at
join you struggle again what is longer
jet just go you could try and see if you
get four people I don't know why those
two Colossus dropped out we're doing
fine it probably cuz they didn't know
how to play Colossus I mean that's not
an insult it's actually a pretty tough
class to figure out yeah but if your
level if you didn't play the previous
demo and you were stuck with Colossus
you bet
like for me I always at the point where
was like oh I just have to I have to
figure it out it's all about it's all
about using that shield so you can
actually pull the shield out and fire
the shock coil at the same time so you
are both mitigating damage with your
shield and damaging enemies with a
passive like over the shoulder shot coil
and then you can switch to flamethrower
in combo it it just devastates small
enemies but those guys you were talking
about the guys who jump up in the air
with the minigun you'll get annihilated
by them like you cannot hang with them
Daniel says crafting in the den was
based on completing the challenges
interesting so Daniel how would I then
like craft abilities for like storm or
anything like that like you just have to
use the abilities enough times or
something once you complete the
challenges on that type of weapon or
ability you can craft based on rarity
hmm huh I will say I really like the
fact that this is not just a parent up
front like it's fun to figure out a game
and it feels like there are certain guns
that are already aware but that also
that Optimus Prime that yeah it is
that also rubs people the wrong way
though cuz they because it's a fresh
that becomes a frustrating thing where
like yeah you don't want to be handhelds
but also yeah I would have liked to know
that to like know that that's how I can
craft more things is by using this
ability because it didn't never told me
that
right like even if it told me once it's
just like oh that's good to know like I
would like to know that I probably would
have never figured that out unless you
told me you know to be fair we also
don't know
you used to it I'm just not gonna get
used to the melee to be fair we don't
know what the core game experience is
like yeah where this is everything so
far that one like I've talked about
because I haven't gotten to any of the
preview events and I haven't watched too
many of the streams personally because I
wanted to experience the game myself
which is weird because I'm always
usually about trying to get as much an
advantage as I possibly can well I think
what I'm getting at those we don't know
we don't know what the campaign is like
and maybe these mechanics are all
introduced in the campaign so we'll
check that out later Daniel I'm very
curious to know thank you for bringing
that up
sorry I'm I'm just my muscle memory is
not going to allow me today to
hot-swappable you have two weeks to
remember that that's the way to do it so
this is the SMG 100% even though it
doesn't say it gets tough Thank You
Daniel I'll check it out later for sure
Optimus Prime Optimus Court dangit crime
you just debated me alright that's well
played optimus currently use two weapons
at the same time not that I know just
switch back and forth they will see
someone's got ice the storm does I envy
that storms coming um somebody did okay
this no I can't do it man I can't can't
get rid of that muscle memory I feel
like every time Aaron melees when he
doesn't like I want the chat to hit F
take a dream and pay respects
oh he's frozen Oh someone just needed
the crap out of that I think there's an
i screen a two for the Ranger which
would be pretty sweet I like I don't
want to rock that oh oh get combo son
boom Shakalaka
hope they're frozen again at least one
of them ends am I gonna hit the right
button I did I love the SMG see this
this looks like a squad or like at least
a couple people that look like they're
trying to do the kombu stuff and you can
see how much of a difference it makes
come this game is all about the combos
like 100% I would go as far as saying
definitely if you're playing the beta
value value combos over level of ability
far yeah but the thing is and I I agree
with you it's just like the thing is
though when you're soloing it's harder
to write cuz like Daniel seems pretty
knowledgeable about the game Daniel do
you know if gear score actually affects
what's going on in like here all right
I'm gonna do all right god
hit the button melee damn it you held
square that time what did I do
you held square cuz you switched weapons
also everybody drink remember what I
taught you last time instead of just
like running forward you should just
double blink forward and hit a triangle
and then go into a Y sorry double blink
into melee if you want to get there fast
like your blink is pretty quick right so
if you like so let's practice if you go
boom boom trying that oh wow alright
there's mine oh yeah no no your melee
did not just walk there I thought I was
awesome for a second hey don't tell me
it wasn't it's okay I thought for a
second - I was like there's no
destructible rocks like that that I
recall oh wait that's right
because there are mine - don't tell me
I'm not awesome
Red Hawk 66 Erik is the hardcore mofo
player on GameSpot that's kind of
accurate depends on the game but yeah
yeah that's that's a fair assessment
I mean I've tamed I've been a little bit
more tame already down whoop in my life
just because I wouldn't say more team I
I now have a fiance and I'm not saying
that my fiance doesn't let me play games
because it's funny I have this this
story that um no when we first started
dating I actually told her I was like
hey I just want to be upfront about this
one you know what my job is I play video
games for a living that's just what her
she tells her friends which is awesome
right but - I told her so by the way I
just want you to know Tuesday night
Tuesday or Wednesday night is actually
rate night you know just me and so I'm
not saying we won't go on any dates on
Tuesday night it's just I want you to
know that there might be Tuesday nights
where I will be gone for three to five
hours or however long it is also that's
reset day and she knew that so now she
tells that story and some people get in
and some people don't but I I haven't
gotten ham on a game in like a long time
I still I can it just depends tell ya I
tried that with my kids and my kids one
said it's my god they said we don't
speak English at this age so we don't
know what you're talking about into nope
yeah I guess nope
stone oh we are playing the storm yeah
which a lot of people really like Bert
you inverted right I did Aaron could
change the controller offers I don't
think it allows you to switch specific
buttons right now there is an alternate
control scheme I did I think it does
swap those two buttons but still like
Meili is he's a stick press like come on
man
everybody knows me lays a stick pressed
it's just that's that's what it is um
just missed it I will find it oh there
it is mark Ford says I hate the respawn
system I at first I was annoyed by it
but I think it's good because it forces
your team to have to like you know play
strategically and then like also revive
safely and there's mechanics to help you
revive safely so I think it's fine in
most or in at least some to maybe maybe
half is too much but in in the areas
you'll be able to respond in other areas
not so much all right I'm gonna give
this eventually so did you do it again I
press F wait are the big guys out yet
yeah there's big guys oh I meant the big
big guys yeah whatever it's fine give
you scenarios give you some let's go big
as I think Daniel I mentioned two which
is like the combo you're running is
pretty good the the machine pistol plus
sniper
I like machine pistols a lot I don't
know I just I I guess in my head like
when I think storm I think like I'm
playing kind of farther back and I just
want to be able to range stuff I don't
know
Aaron destiny melee is not stick press
is what Bob Joan says yeah F there's the
F thank you you and being right Apollo
says melee is a button press tactically
tactical control is always caught in bf
anyway what I'm saying is I would like
the ability to customize it oh the other
thing too about storm is like the reason
why like I'm not so worried about the
weapons is I feel like your abilities
come back so quickly that like I'm just
almost wanting to just be a caster and
yeah there are the thing is like since
you ran this lightening combo the
interesting thing would have been to see
how like it does say 10% so maybe it's
not as interesting but the fun thing
would have been to be quickly lightening
component yeah you could craft that you
could do before you start a mission
unfortunately you can only add one
component at our level but at 20 I think
you can have your second one so I also
got to pay more attention to what's a
primer and what's a detonator well OH
see these guys these guys must know
what's up because they didn't even
bother killing those guys and they just
went for the turn-ins
yeah but also that's how you get your XP
to get your lead drops I thought you
said killing stuff doesn't give you XP
yeah comboing does like killing I think
killing I don't know exactly what it is
but they they basically said killing
like random mobs doesn't give you XP
it's doing things like combos killing
big guys Apollo I agree if like if I was
actually on a xbox oh if I played more
pad stuff on PC the elite controller
would be the way to go the elite
controller just really expensive but I
like the options that the elite
controller gives you just to customize
how you want to you know play cuz I'm
really I've been a PlayStation 4 player
for like ever and it's weird for me now
not have the double thumb sticks in the
in the middle but I know you can do that
with the elite controller yeah you did
it again press F F F F F lightning ball
equals primer let lightning strike
equals detonating really maybe I just
didn't see him combo them two together
but apparently Daniel who is thank you
again for the tips has been super
knowledgeable and helpful it's not
letting me aim it aim it aim it yeah
let's go rescue everybody we can nope
there's a lot of guys here hmm
don't forget your Dodge
and then get out of Dodge yep oh boy Wow
this mission nope no Crouch man I miss
Crouch also played division to you in
there's no Crouch there's no Crouch in
destiny well I guess there kind of is I
guess you can't Crouch I take that back
you really this is not a game you can
Yolo like you really do need to think
about what you're doing
oh that you can't Yolo yet unless you're
gonna be interceptor no because you
don't like I honestly think there will
be builds and like setups at endgame
really will xxx that like I'm sure like
on certain difficulties you'll probably
be able to like run ham like it won't
even matter
like that's how like and and maybe I'm
wrong to view this game like it is
Diablo but like as the progression gets
harder and harder you are getting gear
for that right but it makes everything
below it easier and faster and more
efficient that's what I mean that's not
what you're concerned about in this game
but that's what this game is gonna be is
like how efficient are you at hard
versus the next tier we're like I think
it's grand master grand master one can
you do grand master one yet it says you
need epic but are you really running
inefficiently or should you just be
doing more hard content until you can
actually do it like that's the cool
stuff to me and then it's gonna be
finding out what you know all these
different abilities and component load
outs become and like what is like
they're really cool like super ice build
or like I don't know like there's gonna
be crazy funds that's like the
interesting stuff to me Oh F yes I
cannot do it f I need to be like on my
phone to like do F myself you'll be able
to Yolo after a few anthem Wednesday's
Stephen sorry I'm not gonna try your
last thing because I'm gonna get it
wrong so Stephen W asked GameSpot what
type of system is this running on we
have a i seven 8700 k 32 gigs of ram
with a 1070 sorry I cut you off what's
up f F Oh Leslie says all destiny
players all moving the anthem suit nope
they will probably all move the anthem
the question will be will anthem have
enough to hold the destiny players for a
long period of time that is that is the
bigger question in my mind they are
definitely gonna switch for at least
like two to four weeks if not more than
that and they will probably be making a
lot of content for it there's there's
just that's gonna happen I know that for
a fact well I mean to be fair this is a
really good time for anthem to release
actually you don't really want to go
over there because there's you get
trapped between mines and a couple other
things that's a bad that's a bad spot to
uh to chill sorry back to the first
thought so it's it's it's it's kind of I
don't know depending on what kind of
destiny player you are right now
Destiny's not in a great spot and
there's not enough content so this is a
great time season of The Drifter soon
though we'll see what that even is
though that might just be a couple
gambit maps in another 50 50 lights
power Johnny Rodgers that's close to the
system I have at home which I know feels
bad homburg because it's not that great
but I think you might be able to pull
low off and be okay with that rig is
your i-5 overclocked a Bhama nation Oh 5
what is the idea behind the game so the
idea behind the game is on this planet
the anthem of creation came along like
this is probably one of the things from
it and basically made this planet and
but left before it was finished and so
this is kind of like a planet that's
it's got these machines that can shape
it that are kind of out of control and
they are supposedly constantly going to
change the game over time I think that's
the gist of it like the gods left before
the planet was done is the main hook
Tegan says have you gotten any epic set
no we haven't I don't even know if
purples are in this demo to be gotten
and have you tried customizing the
helmet on storm if you don't know you
can customize helmets yeah you can you
can customize with a gold which you do
get in-game
but yeah we could do that I didn't
customize any of my helmets on any of my
characters I had enough fun just buying
like a cheap vinyl and customizing my
colors super messy lovers says I played
the demo but I still enjoyed destiny
more I can see that I understand some of
the points of perhaps why like for me
destiny still has way better feel when
it comes to shooting the guns feel very
unique and I'm not saying the shooting
in this game is bad by any means it's
just that it just feels like destiny to
me is still one of the best like feeling
shooters out there it's hard to make
third person as get his first person
yeah
but yeah I can see why you feel there we
go haha I did it right melee all right
let's try it tasting that's that's when
you have them frozen or you need to have
a combo yeah how are the how's the FPS
with the gtx 1070 no they've been fine
like I haven't noticed any dips or drops
or anything not necessarily guys I want
to tangle with so I'm guessing I'm not
sure exactly what the video settings are
at right now I would assume they're
either at like Ultra or high we can
check later though see that seems like a
detonator nope see this is why I would
never run the machine gun machine pistol
I would never be near anything I'd be
hiding in a corner casting spells and
shooting long range that's so that's
where the core so the stock ability that
comes with the Hawaii you guys wiped
again no can stop the stock ability
comes with a storm is a freezing ability
come on Optimus Prime he looks badass
but he's not to people asking what do
you think is better how do you think
this will compare to division 2 is kind
of a fair question only because it's
like coming out relatively soon but
Aaron's actually played both yeah I play
both so it really just comes down to
setting to be honest if you like
contemporary and you like you know min
maxing with elemental effects this is
the game if you are really focused on
endgame however it feels like if
- has put more thought into it well
they've also had this is their second
crack yeah like I'd ever Division two
has they are talking about endgame up
front and they're launching with like as
much endgame as possible dang it sorry
we really wanted you to combo that
turret some of the rosen targeting is
some of the targeting is a bit tricky
you do not want to hang on the right
side this boy we've discovered frank
Cola there's only one stronghold right
now see if we can if he seems rescue
able where are you so if you got to flow
15 you'll start this demo on level 15
yes that's correct yeah you're in the
minefield aren't you burrow okay so
here's my impression so far I think
Division two has the endgame figured out
already and is gonna launch to the
40-hour campaign and an endgame good to
go so we don't know how long anthem
anthem campaigns gonna be so I would say
if you're looking for contemporary
setting plus a little bit more longevity
upfront division - if you are looking
for something that just feels a bit more
new and you really like the sci-fi
setting I've really had a good time
playing anthem as well so yeah that's
kind of where I think the two games are
at right now okay there's only three
Daniel now that doesn't mean that that
doesn't mean that anthem won't have an
end game it just seems like they haven't
fully figured it out yet so Danny was
saying that he believed or he's heard
that there's only three strongholds at
launch that's kind of not that many I
thought there'd be more but we'll see
yes as well Hulk nation has mentioned
this demo is the exact same except the
one big nice thing is that the bug bug
bugs are mostly fixed from what I can
tell at least on PC haven't tried on a
ps4 Xbox one heard Xbox just now was
having some difficulties so tension zero
asking did Bioware say anything about
raids
I think they've kind of like softly
commented on it like in the in the vein
that like they probably won't have like
a traditional raid but they will have
like activity I did it like in the
vane of like raids or like not not that
they would be like raid like but that
they would kind of fill that role of
what a raid is in terms of like content
I don't know if I explained that well
there sorry
Shaba is Jackson asking a gangster
what's your favorite chattel and so far
it oh man that's tough I I say that
because I only played a little bit of
interceptor today hey man did
interceptor feel good but I also know
some folks in the the office that played
interceptor first and kind of got sick
of it but the nice thing is you're
leveling your pilot and so you can kind
of switch javelins at any time I feel
like I'm not a huge fan of the Colossus
yet but again this is based on my
experience in the demo and I feel like
there's more to be explored there so
classes could be super fun I mean the
lightning coil flamethrower combo was
pretty pretty clutch yeah once once I
figured out Colossus I actually really
grew to like it quite a lot it's a very
nuanced well-liked at least in the demo
like you need to run very specific
builds but once you do you're a minion
clearing badass like I almost feel like
I want a rock Ranger and just find a way
to Ranger main because I bet you could
do that like I feel like you could do
that Rob really likes Ranger and I think
Ranger you know again is the one that
detonates combos the strongest versus
individual enemies so by the way sorry
Division two does have confirm raids
eight player raids believe their cuz
that at launch they've been talking
about it a bit okay just curious if that
was like alright cool
watch out stuff that's one the other end
game element is legendary contracts
which are yeah so yes as the I know
mentioned legendary contracts are
basically like the missions you've done
except there's probably like harder and
have like maybe kind of some different
aspects he's like let's just read what
he wrote which I random like single
mission single-player missions with
multi parts I think the plus back is
that there are six difficulty types that
you can should keep content interesting
ah I don't know if difficulty alone is
enough if there's not enough places to
go and try and do stuff because like if
you think of a stronghold in the same
vein that you would think of like a
Wow or something like that there's so
many dungeons in wow that you're going
through you know to try to get loot and
things like that it would actually be
really awesome if they had I mean again
we're not
I can't hard confirm that there's only
three strongholds but if that's what
Daniel is heard and he's been pretty
knowledgeable so far I would hope that
like those dungeons to have like
specific you know maybe like epic or
certain pieces of gear that that would
drop that you would then like farm just
that specific stronghold and if there
was enough strongholds you could kind of
make one per stronghold right but you
know they'll probably add stuff down the
road so all right where's my team at
there wasn't much guys chasing me this
is really a bad arturo rios already
asking like what would you want in
future future javelin or javelins
ah that's i haven't played enough of all
four to like be like what class is
missing i guess i mean i mean i guess
you could have a healer class i don't
know how how fun that would be for the
person this is not guys playing the
healer my team but okay maybe they're
like but i'm sure like someone's gonna
come up with some cool crazy stuff
that's like support storm or things like
that i would imagine but the only thing
i could think of is there's not actually
healer class i don't know if you
actually need one though it yeah maybe
it feels like there's a lot of room for
these builds to I mean we're just kind
of scratching the surface with what
these builds are yeah Red Hulk that
division Lu's gonna be a purple hat in a
parka jacket yep hell yeah man you need
giving that sick baseball hat actually I
think that baseball hat was like a
cosmetic the game is Ironman destiny
sure I mean yes and no I mean it's
always easier to compare something to
something but I think Aaron's point of
like it's like Mass Effect multiplayer
yeah or a co-op is kind of accurate it
feels a lot more like but in these cool
javelins honestly this feels exactly
like Mass Effect co-op plus Mass Effect
I just I think it's exactly that
I wouldn't even compare it to much else
to be honest oh the microtransactions
will definitely not be as bad as
battlefront in the vein that it won't
affect the gameplay it's all aesthetic
my couldn't choose cuz everybody gave up
if they did then we'll call it on tire
mines cuz nope I don't like your
attitude
well it's like a 45 mission with 45 min
admission with a good team I don't think
it's 45 minutes with a good team okay
maybe but four times with a bad team
would you say yeah I think 45 minutes to
an hour is fair for a team that might
not be as coordinated I think this team
is not as cool I think there's only this
one guy now because I think the other
two guys left to be fair was weird
because I had no problems during the the
beta clearing this thing I mean like I
not said I didn't have like deaths or
three swans and things like that but
like I never had to drop out I guess
Optimus let's go Optimus yeah let's just
stay together in wool we'll do this
together well yeah I mean you bring up a
good point I mean like if you guys can't
get through it then whatever I mean and
you're kind of running out of time
anyways but I'll be here for you chat I
think for the most part
this kind of reminds me of one aspect of
whole destiny where the other thing too
is like I don't know if folks out there
like in our pit are playing but we could
also group up with them that could make
running the stronghold easier as well
you know this this also might be the
result of just kind of a weird combo of
old and new players so we got people
from the VA but yep you know what
they're up to button yeah but there was
two players that at least got to 12
right because they had a colossus and
javelin or uh interceptor and the other
guy had storm so they I feel like they
definitely have at least maybe they
haven't got through the stronghold
though who knows trying to get a I mean
to get this game is all about the combos
nope somebody behind us oh yeah there's
a guy behind us and he's big
you know honestly he's on PC uses
controller yeah because wait till you
try to playing PC flying does not feel
that good on a keyboard mouse it feels
better it's it's hard to play a third
person I think with keyboard mouse for
personally but you know you can play it
however you want like the world is your
oyster I don't know why people want to
judge others for like for the longest
time in the fgc in the fighting game
community people frowned upon players
that played on pad and now look at how
many players play on pad like for
certain games and are very successful
like I don't think that's fair like I
guess in the same vein that then for me
I don't like the flying on keyboard
mouse but maybe you all like it so I
don't know how do you unlock new
javelins I did all the campaign ray get
to level 12 and you'll unlock at least
one other javelin and then I'm not sure
if it'll auto unlock everything else for
you but it they eventually did that on
Sunday last beta so maybe this Sunday
before the event if you're just joining
into the demo the open dino demo they
will unlock the characters for you
javelin so switch over to interceptor
because I definitely want to try that
one so yeah you know again I didn't have
any problems last weekend but on this
stream twice in a row we've had teams
give up on tyrant mines which is weird
cuz you were saying I cleared it
multiple times with randoms yeah I don't
know
so yeah and you know what could because
the core builds of these are pretty
straightforward and then once you start
tweaking them you can actually come with
that come up with bad load outs that is
possible I was able to I don't know if I
was in a mission or not with a pretty
bad load on Colossus but maybe I got
carried through that one or something
good and toasty not in the traditional
sense of a red no chief banana warframe
looks different in this patch yeah
definitely not warframe but I can see
why you're saying that
ultimate inscription throwing stars all
right how did you like the the
interception let's go back to
interceptor I liked it but well Hulk
nation says no you can't get all the
javelins unless you play the V every
general yet at least right now like
you'll be able to unlock one at 12 and
then my hope is that everyone else like
we did last week during the VIP demo on
Sunday would then also hope that Bioware
EA decide to unlock the rest of them for
everyone else as well I could see that
they they already teased some big event
on Sunday
and last time they unlocked all the
javelins for everybody later Daniel
thank you again for stopping by and drop
in the hot knowledge enjoy going back to
work I guess maybe's already at work
alex says I just played tired minds a
little while ago it didn't seem any
harder easier compared to the VIP demo
yeah it's it's the same thing like the
content is the same if you played VIP
demo all the stuff that's in the current
demo is the same come back on Sunday
yeah Sunday there was an event I don't
know what time it is but that would be
the only difference and then maybe the
only other subtle difference I would say
is a you know maybe you're by playing
you're getting some new abilities that
you didn't have previously on specific
javelins do you feel like there is an
elemental ability imbalance um I haven't
played enough to be honest to give you
that assessment I've just been trying to
like go through and get as many Oh cry
ugly that's nice that's nice mister I've
been trying to go through and just try
different abilities that I've been
earning sometimes I picked the highest
one but not always
I feel like Isis
really good though from what I've seen
just because it it has the ability to D
habilitated and then it leads into
pretty good easy combos I feel like have
you pissed this demo is way better than
when the VIP demo launched yes I totally
agree like the bugs from what I've seen
at least on PC are gone they are
non-existent the loading bugs are gone
the servers have been stable like we
were able to get in right away uh so
they must have sorted out a bunch of
stuff somebody asked about changing the
helmet yeah you just have to pay your
coins where I mean you can do it if you
want doesn't matter this just this stuff
doesn't carry over the open exploration
has some mini quest missions also that
was interesting yeah I just feel like
the open-world exploration as it stands
in the demo doesn't feel as robust as I
feel like it should have been I'd agree
the open world feels too empty it like
the the free room in particular feels
like it needs more I'm andrée saying
he's having trouble logging on and so
are lots of his friends do you know what
platform you're on I heard Xbox is
having difficulties at least before I
got on the stream so maybe like Xbox did
have some of the biggest problems too I
think last weekend PC had its problems
but I heard more troubles for logging in
for Xbox I didn't try though personally
ok let's not do tire minds
let's do when I start the game and
automatically opens the settings menu
and I can't close it isn't anyone else
having this problem I restarted multiple
times are you hitting Carter are you
running into that thing where it like
like the first splash screen where like
if you click a button it pops up like
Windows Explorer or your browser because
if that's the case you just need to hit
escape or back some of the menus aren't
the best what do you think about the
high temperatures of CPU that anthem
causes on PC that is a thing at least on
a lower end PC that I could speak about
specifically I was telling you that my
computer sounded like it was an airplane
ready to take off when I was playing at
certain parts of like missions it
definitely was eating up my CPU now
granted I had like my rig is like six
years plus old or so so it's only got
like an i-5 in it
but it was taking up 90 plus percent of
my CPU so if you I don't think it's
doing that here like I'd have to I don't
have a second monitor on our game play
machine for me to like pull that up
without like pulling up task manager to
show you guys but I don't I don't
imagine it being difficult on like a rig
that's maybe like a year or two old but
it depends on what you have I would
assume
or you know just live in Chicago right
now it's not a problem heat up your
house with your PC also stay safe cuz
it's like negative 50 over there please
let this be a destiny clone I'm tired of
paying for $60 DLCs for destiny it's not
destiny clone yeah you know if so
there's a couple times but honestly
actually in place class yet um freezes
which is really awesome nice okay like
people keep comparing this to different
games but honestly it's just I feel like
it's exactly Mass Effect co-op once Mass
Effect cleave is sorry to cut you off
there it's a it's almost exactly okay so
that's blades okay some of these are
definitely better melee classes than
others yes so that's a detonator it
another turret um what's the what's the
double it's not like a war shot or
something I'm not sure did you change
your Excuse a same I don't recall to be
honest we'd have to look at it after
nope really also you do have like
knowledge on this character which is
pretty good okay yeah so like somebody's
class like this one a directional one
this one's probably someone seems like
more of a melee class like it you might
even just be good going in melee did you
change my components because one of my
components was like a do more melee
damage one and it gives you more health
which is pretty sweet I'm doing pretty
good work with just melee here yeah it
does it's quite a bit of damage
what's then what's the devil oh yeah I'm
about to go down there we got a backflip
and yeah sorry so interrupted thought
this feels exactly like Mass Effect's
co-op plus Mass Effect it's like
somewhere in between the two and I think
honestly that's where it's at
hockey game saying lots of people
playing intercept or any reason or
people just prefer that one I think
people prefer this one just because it
like one has a really cool flip when
you're flying it's got really good
mobility I don't know I think maybe
those players played hunter maybe in
destiny and this kind of channel some of
that I don't know because like storm is
almost like a caster this is character
is almost like kind of like your
assassin type class oh really Rangers
kind of like just your soldier and then
you know Colossus as we've mentioned in
the current build or what we've gotten
doesn't feel like a traditional tank
which is why the tank east of the
although you said you could make the
argument that maybe even interceptor is
kind of a tanky because you just have
you know you have to be in there right
so you got to be able to survive and
like this ultimate you basically are
invulnerable from what I've never died I
went up to like one of those bosses and
just like was spamming it and it was
doing work so okay
it's definitely of the most flourish of
any class like the take off yeah cross
play no not that we know the flying
feels so good in this game honestly
but yeah even the difficulty system
that's just Mass Effect co-op sage
warfarin player here is this game
pay2win because if it is and I want to
try the open beta it's not pay to win
you can't there's nothing that you can
pay for that will affect the actual game
gameplay the only thing that really
changes is aesthetics of your javelins
so it's not pay to win and I would say
since the beta since the open beta is
free I would just say try it see if see
if as a warframe player you like it or
if you just for whatever reason still
feel like you know warframe is a better
game for you you know so it's definitely
not pay to win though this but it is pay
to get early access though in a way you
know there if that would be the one
thing that feels kind of like awkward is
like they have to give you a chart of
like here are all the days you can play
if you have this you can play on the
15th if you have this you can play on
this day if you don't have that you know
what I mean like that's weird to me like
what happened to just like playing on
said day but I don't know that's so kind
of like like what the life of a
president a exclusivity but you know
there's timed exclusive well you're
crazy
who does the glaive bounce
ha the flourish on my class is actually
pretty impressive game just kicked me
out of ps4 I would just say try real
logging in it has usually you can just
rejoin expedition pretty easily it has
it yeah it has a pretty good resume
feature you cannot fly as long as you
want Kevin Bacon you actually have a
meter underneath and if you you if it if
you do it for too long you overheat
however you can do things like find your
water to cool it you can also have
components and things like that so that
you can fly longer so there are ways to
make it so you can fly longer but you
can't indefinitely fly it
oh that's cool it does bounce the glaive
that is and then that's a detonator this
glass will break you have your your
reload habit the the glaive has a really
long cooldown though which is which
makes sense because of like its
effectiveness that I've seen so far but
I'm sure there's ways that you could
potentially reduce that yep
I should have detonated that with the
time to get out of Dodge
no it's not it's time to bleed dance
nope
I hit it I hit it I just didn't hit in
time let's see what happens here your
colossus is using his murat no he's dead
too
that's not how that works sorry is there
one guy there's gotta be one person left
right left
yeah there's two of them run away so you
should be alright we're all
experimenting with low deaths I will say
like I had some very many customizations
available in demo it seems decent like
part of it is uh like hopefully getting
the abilities to drop so you can try
other stuff but Daniel in chat earlier
was saying that like crafting some of
those things is conditioned on finishing
colleges so I need to take a look at the
challenges it's a trend if we can do
that we can craft some of those
abilities that was killing them then
everybody killed you spawn herds burn
isn't it yeah I think you're right I
think they'd be spawned you gotta go
talk to there's melee damage effect
Titans
I think only as they're like casting
something so like I did the interceptors
ultimate when he was just standing there
and it was doing zero damage to Kenny
that is
you know how a dance moves yet
yeah we're just currently playing the
demo the open demo that's available for
anyone that wants to download it
currently in quick play missions if you
play the VIP demo everything's the same
so far until Sunday
- whatever stuff you you find obviously
that you didn't have previously got a
wave some of the deals good into us he
says I know that Bioware is working on
cross play do you know exactly when
exactly that will be applied after
launch I don't know if it'll happen you
know like one Sony has to be Sony seems
to be the one that has to be like cool
with it and the thing that I don't know
makes me moderate like minorly
just like hesitant to say like you'll
you'll get that cross play is the fact
that like you know Xbox and PC are gonna
get this game a whole week early for in
comparison to anyone that's playing on
ps4 so you can see this bottom meter
that Erin's at like if he doesn't stop
soon which he did he would have
overheated and then you can couldn't use
your like boosters for a bit loading
screen how is it though GS guys asked
Peter hashing I'm having a fun time but
I like loot based games I'm interested
to see how it feels like after playing
2030 hours though like I've only played
the demo and since I haven't played too
much preview stuff beforehand I'd
definitely have been just messing around
with a different javelins and just
experiencing that so for now I'm having
fun but again it's very early so I
that's all I can say is like but the
good news is you know if you haven't
played the demo you should try it just
see if you like it it's free this
weekend
so why not that was not detonator cause
it didn't say combo these guys died
really fast
what's double bumper on this class so
that like a shout oh I don't know that's
why I said the only way for us to tell
is we'd have to oh yeah uses ultimate
the ultimat for the colossus is
basically like you have you can come
like an artillery strike you get like
three shots of like a heavy mortar
essentially the class is almost like the
first mission I believe to Colossus also
does get a knock back and kind of
stacker damage with their melee yeah if
you pull the shield out you can kind of
like knock people over that's how you
kind of kind of help to with some of
those bigger elite guys because you can
knock them over like almost like stagger
them here's the glyph puzzle we'll see
if these folks know what's up but as I
said each one has like a answer so this
is the one where everybody can be off
doing their own thing and kind of mess
up this puzzle so one of them has a
glyph Carter yeah I'm not too sure like
the only thing I could say is as someone
mentioned follow the ticket but or me I
mean as crappy as it sounds you could
try uninstall reinstalled but feel like
I've never I've never heard of that
problem to the two today so got really
dark oh did we play the closed alpha I
mean if you mean VIP demo like last week
we did oh you mean the closed alpha from
like a while ago I did not you tried but
you couldn't get in right oops I got in
for a day like at the very end of it
here right yeah so this is where
everybody's trying to do something
different I need to just stand here and
guard it so there's the glyph right
there question is do they know the
answers to the other ones and if they
don't then they're just gonna kind of
come around and I think this one's
purple unless it's glowing yellow to
your left
yeah that one's purple when you're at
and then the other one the guys at is
yellow hope that Mele isn't just a
single move set I think you had that
like jumping Mele but other than that it
looks like it's just one Mele animation
right now but it's different for every
javelin yeah but and I think doesn't the
Ranger is the Ranger has like a club
that's also its own yeah like a club
baton thing it's there's a sufficient
amount of variety between suits like it
I haven't been to I feel like I play
each one pretty differently so I think
it just depends on the skills and how
many skills there are and how many
combinations you can come up with
because I could see like it like
everyone else's concerns like if there
if there isn't enough stuff to do other
than difficulty then it's gonna become a
problem it doesn't matter if the
javelins like I like at some point
they're switching javelins isn't gonna
do anything no wasn't for you what it
wasn't complete was it yeah was you
finish the mission really by finishing
the puzzle that's it yeah okay well
that's that mission that's the first
mission that's yeah that's why I got two
new people I'm gonna hand the controller
values must earn a world is a good game
by yeah I enjoyed monitoring the world
um that game is a very long game yeah
even in single-player it's a long game
and then if you go min max your
character you're gonna spend ooh
okay so rally cry which is probably what
we had brakes your allies from status
fix okay and then you get all these
bonuses which is pretty good pickup
radius is very good actually just
because it helps you probably pick up
health which is probably pretty
important for any receptor weird that
they cut the mission there yeah that
actually felt a little Brooks but it's
like taste it is the first mission damn
that Colossus it hideous yeah that's why
you got to make your own we saw one
earlier that looked like Optimus Prime
it was actually legit except he did not
he did like he was Optimus
which is the problem obviously you
didn't know how to play Colossus which
is again it's a beserker it's really not
a tank at this point
chica 21 says he's eager to play not
concerned about the story combat
movement is where it's at I totally
agree I think the the outstanding
portions of this game so far are the
movement flight in the combat combo
systems are fun they're really enjoyable
Andrew if you played VIP temmo depending
on how high of a level you got - you
should have unlocked another javelin at
12 and I think you'd be loaded in at on
Sunday you should have got all of them
so I feel like you might have all them I
feel like if Aaron goes back to his desk
he'll probably have all of them but
cannot confirm that until he does it was
to shield recharge seems pretty good
yeah they unlocked him oh I think you
just said this but they unlocked them
all at the end of the VIP demo and
because progress doesn't carry over to
the main game you might as well spend
your customization points chat want me
to play something else
I mean I could show you the cool
Colossus build oh I have it
my Colossus is the exact same mmm how's
the flamethrower and the shock oil shock
well Lightning coil
yeah I mean this thing's a beast when it
comes to clearing minions I could play
Colossus if you guys want to see that
what dang it I can play any of them to
be honest I think four in terms of the
question game background for PvP there's
no I don't think is any confirmed PvP it
was just it was kind of like a we'll
look into it later thing Kevin Ryan you
don't need a span you're unhappy face I
see the one
let's see pro play it's ok play there
download link it depends on what
platform you're on if you're on PC need
to have origin if you're on ps4 go to
the store same with the Xbox ok not too
many answers in terms of like what you
guys want to see one interceptor and one
storm right now
the views are at 666 yeah it's evil
storm alright we'll try storm yeah I
mean the early comments I think so far
in PvP just reading right now is they'll
they'll think about it I don't think
there's any confirmed PvP at the moment
I'm not even really sure how that would
work it's not something they ever really
bothered with with Mass Effect co-op
throw rapid bolts of fire oh so this is
like the ice one sure we'll just try
something different
no people really like the storm I think
in general people have enjoyed the storm
because it's it's one of those classes
probably one of the two classes where
you don't rely very much on your on your
guns honestly with the right build you
don't have to shoot very much some of
these abilities come back real quick
well that's pretty cool looking yeah
I'll switch helmets why not where's the
sound effect oh that's what I'm saying
like they need that satisfying you never
know this like we mentioned this is the
this could be an old build you know show
more abilities Oh different abilities uh
all right I can still do the Forge from
the main menu thingy so alrighty I got a
duck out sounds good but uh plant
today's gonna keep going with you guys
and honestly stick around next week
we're working on some stuff today to
show you guys that you'll probably
really enjoy cool have fun day
oh thanks oh we got ice storm I'd sick
we got a we got a freezing spell nice
so I'm gonna try the burning or because
you guys saw the lightning orb slide to
the middle I'm guessing you muted that
microphone or your microphone yeah cool
I'm gonna slide this chair over it's sit
like right in the middle also gonna turn
this monitor a little bit all right so
we're gonna try out burnin orb and ice
storm right now got that double kind of
like ranged type thing if you guys want
me to use a different weapon I can try
um the only other thing we have is a
shotgun our assault rifle or pistol um
so I think I should just get going
though before you guys lose interest are
the servers good to go yes they are
Benjamin do you guys want me to do
try the stronghold again or do you guys
want me to do just missions
I mean missions will probably let us go
through more javelins but you know we
could do we could do some other stuff
it's up to you guys I know there's some
delay on chat though so I need your help
I'll give it a second
this lowers the fall I'm definitely not
stronghold all right all right let's go
strong hold it up hopefully we can get
there so we can show you the spider boss
and all that stuff
the spider boss feels to me like think
sorry sorry I saw the missions late I
don't have a good gauge of the primers
detonators yet I haven't looked at a
list I'm sure there's gonna be like a
guy that will like me like here's all
the primers that we know our primers
you're all the detonators which is kind
of cool because you know it's like
almost like if you guys played like
Final Fantasy one of the MMORPG is back
in the day Oh sick see this is the
beauty of when people leave so we're
basically like back to like where Aaron
was oh we already have our alt
interesting
oh we can spam these ok the fire is not
a detonator for whatever you
do I have infinite shuriken x' what just
happened there my like lagging
it's weird like I definitely wait is my
own guy mailing me come on bro cuz look
I'm holding down left bumper and the
ability it's oh there goes oh so maybe I
don't spam all five and it will come
back sorry I've never used that ability
so alright we beat that part this groups
already doing it we're doing way better
than earlier I guess just shot that mine
on me come up no just four at a time
oh are you talking about the number of
players pc beta I'm playing on
controller yeah I'm playing on
controller but we're playing PC it's
just a preference you guys can play
however you want if you want keyboard
mouse I felt the flying personally to be
a little bit more intuitive with the
controller I also just played
that's just how I play it I guess and
then after playing PlayStation you're
just kind of used to it yes how do
combos work so with certain abilities
you can it's like a primer right once
you use it if somebody follows up
immediately with like a detonator
ability then it'll say combo so I think
if I froze something with my ice
chickens if the other storm does a
lightning the lightning attack that will
combo and there's other combinations of
skills that will do that too now the one
thing that sucks about this part is I
think we're missing our one dude who's
like really far away and I don't think
we can start until he gets here which is
oh wait there you go or maybe he left
we got triple storm right now and I
guess it's okay I mean we we were
successful so far so hello
interesting so as long as I like don't
overly spam the ice ability it looks
like I can kind of like keep using it
whereas the the solar attack has an
actual like number on it that's
interesting what about the combo we just
got blew off killing random stuff I like
that what about the comments between
javelins yeah there's definitely some of
that too I think Aaron and I can't
confirm this because this is just based
off what Aaron said but he was saying
that the Ranger can potentially do the
like most solo damage as a detonator so
yeah like that's where it's gonna get a
little bit more intricate you know
you're gonna work with your team to do
combos and you know work on oh that was
a thing that we needed
that's interesting this must be there
you go okay got to grab the relics each
of these rope caves have one eye for the
longest time didn't know you have to
like walk up to it and place it because
the echoes themselves like you just well
there's two in here all right
so we picked this up we can't fly
anymore which is unfortunate we can jump
I guess we couldn't hover that's pretty
but that's just because we're storm but
the server's just just I owned for
everyone else at the moment no we're
still in
if possible let's try not to come into
someone else's chat and like try to ask
for subscribers kind of a rude thing to
do so you come back to these things
place it I've gotta get some more
and then we're gonna kind of the king of
the hill that spot in a little bit Thank
You Ryan for helping with the do trying
to get some sibs
alright it looks like I got the last
school alright so now we probably gotta
do the king of the hill part which is
like it's a ramp so like they're just a
bunch of stuff that's gonna spawn so
we'll oh okay so I can hold that down
Hadouken oh darn it I shot one too many
ice shards there man that is a pretty
good ability
I feel like you have like I wouldn't say
half to you but like I feel like having
one person on your team have I see it's
too good to pass up
kinda this is what it's like with like
three storms here guys I'll freeze them
for you
oh I used one too many can throw these
small fireballs or you can charge it
storm look soapy uh I mean in this case
cuz we're just killing the like little
ads it feels that way but they're all
that all the classes feel pretty good
ha Tolkien don't worry team I will help
freeze
ah that that's the only thing is when
they walk up to you and like blockier
your stuff from the hitting that's kind
of annoying but not a big deal
use your ultimate please uh it's
probably too late for that I'm gonna
save it for the boss cuz you can you'll
see the ultimate plenty of times against
the boss basically like you basically
spam super right away and then like you
just do it again and that's like that's
like the main source of damage almost I
feel like against the spider boss
go see though you'll see the ultimate
don't worry
dude this is a good group let's go grab
that ammo good shout oh yeah triple blue
or oh it's a rare amber we got you baby
double blue in a remember oh no we got
triple rare oh let's go
what a crazy drop oh we didn't need to
kill that guy we should just go catch up
to the rest of our team and kill the
boss so that we can show you guys some
other javelins
come on warrior you're you're
distracting me I want to shoot that
stuff to you but actually if those guys
are like super ahead they'll just pull
us forward to be honest
oops I just went the wrong way didn't I
feel like I went the wrong way
supposed to go into the water no I did
go the right way whoops yeah you just
gotta jump into the water in a second
that's fine someone's teleporting this
that's fine three rares Wow testy can
learn I'm bored erase those counts there
yeah as Steven said if you're bored you
don't have to watch totally fine or if
you want to hang out in chat that's cool
but you know thanks for stopping by I
guess I appreciate it either way
appreciate all y'all for being here
either way what's up box Knight how you
doing so here's a big spider boss I will
use the ultimate once I can on on on her
we are you free for damage
we're not comboing right now though oh
there you go
need somebody to like move the boss of
course that was pro play right there
missing that snipe I can get mr. Rogers
now though I think maybe do you put your
bubble up oh we should not all be
together that is like the lasting one on
this boss
okay I am bad this is where mouse
keyboard would probably be better huh
in a run
we got one of the crit spots down now we
play the kill the little guys game cuz
they're just gonna spawn a bunch in the
corner that she walks away from so like
over here my buddy's to be over here
though
oh okay that was my bad
and she charges out of the cave after
usually we kill the the little spiders
like way faster but that's to be
expected with three storms I feel like
oh don't both be here thank you
and as mentioned you're basically just
coops supering the crap out of these
boss
hate how that kills the reload animation
sometimes though
so now we set up for this and hopefully
I don't get killed this time from
staying too long overstay my welcome
see I hit my teammate again I think it's
kind of frustrating anyway that's fine
it's nice actually the TEL is a and I'm
stupid for not paying attention tor is a
the boss's name will come back up when
it's gonna come out
and then see ultimate fest again
it's why gonna leave seem to be honest
because we did so much damage to it
thinks shooting it's actually better
than casting at that point because I'm
doing like 464 crits
it's not friendly fire but they can get
in the way of your abilities though
still not sold on if I should enter the
frost ability kind of feel like it's
nice to just be able to free stuff
because I can do this right and then
just not digging as I say that but you
can do it and then not like hit the last
like attack on it and then actually be
able to just like save it and see look
now you get the ultimate again and the
three storms are putting two ultimate
the crab at the boss so I don't know how
this boss does anything against like
anyone that's gonna like basically do
that over and over
but this group isn't pretty good
obviously as you can see and my lone
death was totally on my on me I didn't
get out of the way so no triple storm
Ranger not even sure if the Ranger uses
his ability what's also weird it's like
after you beat this boss right
like you'd feel like there'd be a chest
or the boss would drop loot but it
doesn't like that's weird to me all
right so we can play another class I can
run a couple more missions or something
and then you know enjoying the stream
enjoying hanging out with the all thanks
to of course Aaron who's no longer here
with me on the stream because he is a
real adult and has oh I'm real adult too
but he has meetings to get to so he was
nice enough to join in for a couple
hours but yeah like I can do you know
another mission or two or something we
haven't played Colossus I could
definitely do that if you guys want to
see that skip this oh I like the the
look of the storm on the far right mr.
Rogers very sleek look yes I am playing
on xbox one controller right now
actually a Latino Chico you plan on what
platform PC I'm just using a controller
let's see if we got anything good or new
pulse blasts I think that's a ranger
ability you've got another shotgun just
salvage it
whatever ooh fire inscription
unfortunately it's only fire based
abilities we got another ice storm that
we have already get rid of that arc
burst is a new ability
um we got Chain Lightning or something
got another melee inscription got a
level 19 sniper that's good yeah so tell
me what you guys uh you guys want to see
something specific and I'll
try to switch it up here no problem de
brill thanks for hanging out gaming
d-pad wants that Colossus gameplay
alright you can do that oh we got booted
to the loading screen alright that's the
first time dominate your teases Colossus
alright assuming I can get back in I
will play Colossus didn't have problems
earlier getting in so we'll see it's
like warframe question mark um some
elements perhaps not totally though
alright where you look like we're okay
getting back in Jacob Churchill also
asking for Colossus we can do that is
the open demo improved from the past
weekend J Darrow the improvement I would
say is definitely this is the first time
I've even been kicked from the game I
haven't had the loading bug error
loading screen error and it didn't take
any time for me on PC at least to get
into the demo so I think just by virtue
of that yes those are improvements in
terms of the actual like gameplay that
you can do not too much different other
than if you're getting abilities that
you didn't have previously that you want
to try so Anthon broken many blue screen
error expedition drop really I haven't
had any problems so I don't know yeah
Latino Tiago says I'm not going to demo
now because it's free so why not give it
a go yeah it's a great time to try it
out if you want to just to get a feel of
if you think you're gonna play it or not
I was wondering if this is what that
person was saying earlier you have to
hit exit or like be to get out of that
menu and I don't I don't know if they're
just getting stuck in the bad or if it
was something else
so much comparison question is just play
the devil yeah a lot of people just need
to know like what they're getting
themselves into and that's fair you know
like time is important right to people
and they'd rather be informed of like
what the experience may or may not be so
that they don't waste their time so
they're definitely gonna compare it to
other games I mean I've said on GameSpot
live multiple times now that maybe even
I do a bad job of like comparing
like a bad job in the sense that I
compare games to other games and maybe
that's not fair I don't know I feel like
it's one of the easier ways to kind of
explain to someone like on a very base
level like hey this games like warfare
anymore this games like destiny and they
kind of have like a thought in mind
already and then you can kind of get
into the nitty-gritty
so yeah this game is similar to man in
nineteen not gonna buy hilarious Super
Bowls this weekend though alright so
we're gonna play the Colossus my
Colossus is got that flamethrower shot
coil build going on check that out we're
gonna use shield pulse which is the
mitigation one there is the battle cry
that technically like pulls aggro oh we
can change our guns though if we want so
I have cloud burst which is like a
colossus specific weapon we can swap out
of the Devastator we could use a shotgun
let's try shotgun we haven't played with
a shotgun at all and will be somewhat up
close and personal I think we are good
to go how are you playing it now as
Blueboy gaming um open demo is available
for anyone so if you want to check that
out go for it I'm gonna do missions only
because it'll be faster than doing a
full on stronghold and I'm probably
gonna do a couple and then we'll
probably call it a stream maybe Ranger I
could do Ranger for sure next Dylan Gogh
de Brill or Deborah willsez Rams rigged
yeah I really wanted the Saints to go
it's a it's an unfortunate shame on that
call it was like I immediately got up
off my scenes like dude how does that
not P I or defenseless receiver I enjoy
and watch a lot of football obviously a
49ers fan it was a tough year for us but
some highlights like George cattle and
things like that I also play flag
football myself so it's like I would
immediately be complaining myself what
type is the Ranger DPS oh we can find a
match matchmaking will automatically
start a few seconds okay ah the Ranger
has a bunch of different you know what
will play Ranger after this because we
played the other two classes and I feel
like yeah let's do some Ranger after the
Ranger is what you start with and so
yeah blend the rest not there Rams yes I
I don't blame the Rams at all I think
that there was a blown call there but
you could counter argue by saying Jared
Goff kind of got his facemask pulled a
little bit on like I think the drive
before and they didn't call it it's
tough but who knows nine your fan here -
oh nice awesome
I can't even launch a game says you yogu
it's weird that I am not kidding
alright let's uh just trying to
matchmake again also we'll make a
consumable consumables if you didn't
know you can craft different kinds that
you can then slot in you can use more
you can technically have more than one
slot once your higher level so what we
want we want like a increased armor I
think or HP if there is one melee fire
combo oh there is no I guess we'll just
do this one
do the gear inscription one okay all
right let's see if we can get a mission
again or not did it hold it okay let's
see if the missions work if not we could
try free roaming or we could just
stronghold again what strongholds just
take a while I actually didn't play
enough a firefall calf boy to give you
an informed decision on that guys I
can't login can someone help me are you
on Xbox mando I heard there's some
problems on mando a B will be a great
addition to the Niners hopefully that
goes through see so like me and my
friends have been hyped about that and
like I'm an AV fan I know he's Deva but
that's how wide receivers are I feel
like for the most part other than like a
I don't know Megatron is the only guy I
can think of that's not super diva
that's like a high tier wide receiver
anyways yeah I guess hmm that's not
working
oh let's so let's just try going as a
free play for a little bit mess around
there and then try missions again I
guess oops you're playing on PC too
that's interesting I'm not sure then I
haven't had any problem logging in but
yeah the Niners got a B that would be
crazy just having a top tier y receiver
in a top tier tight end is insane and I
mean if you look at our offense
considering how many injuries we had we
were still like above middle pack in the
league which is crazy right my problem
is that I don't know like with all the
stuff that abies been saying to try to
get to the Niners and this and that I
just feel like if I'm Pittsburgh I'm
like dude I'm not trading you to the
Niners unless they give us like a
boatload you know but who knows you
never know maybe he's been so toxic on
that team we're toxic for that team that
like they just want to get rid of him I
mean he'll if you guys follow basketball
at all I know this is an anthem shame
but like the kristaps porzingis trade
was like crazy to me too but we're gonna
do Leslie there are women in this game
actually I think my character is
actually female you can't see her
because it's a
first person to avatar in for Tarsus but
there's the girl
there's a girl near the forge so my
health is interesting I think the feel
like the health UI looks different than
last week from what I recall so here's
me with a shield out I don't have a
dodge kill these Dominion guys charge
into them as Aaron mention you can kind
of like oh dang good died all right
here's the lightning coil oh no I don't
want to kill this lizard thing
sorry lizard thing got the flamethrower
see so like with the Colossus as Aaron
mentioned you pretty much have to just
be like in the fray and like it's like
look at my health right now like I'm
melting
I might even die you do regen a little
bit of health but like not that much
yeah I see you like I got some back
guys wrecking me so everyone knows this
is when I would need to like fight some
of those like weaker dudes like that my
flamethrower is doing nothing to him
good knowing everyone rest in peace Oh
burn Oh die eventually right oh my gosh
shield back
yes I don't know like that guy it was
really hard and I am I'm probably
playing Colossus wrong in that regard
like there's probably something I
could've did that I just wasn't doing
against them
Colossus needs to be more tanky I agree
like I like the game is not fully out
yet so oh you can't be down here no no I
don't want a load screen wait take it
out one crash for me so far ps4 two and
half hours so far so good yeah that's
pretty good
later crime thanks for stopping by how
did they get in I've been in since the
beginning wall 10 a.m. actually I didn't
try at 9:00 but we couldn't get any
missions going which is unfortunate I
would much rather be doing a mission
than free roam because like I said free
roam I feel like that with that much
stuff to kill and like all you're really
doing is like harvesting stuff
said I'm killing wildlife
but sometimes disappear on me I guess
like I just don't get why like there
aren't more enemies like here like you
you think like yeah see like there you
go like you feel like there should be
like more though enemies that you should
be like fighting
oops see so like oops you'd want to be
like up in the fray and like killing
stuff getting your health back going all
these like lower tier mobs
you kind of like knock them down to like
you kind of get it right flame on
it's got a rare out of that's cool
so I don't know it just doesn't feel as
fun to play I guess I don't know
that's a combo all right good to know
so flamethrower into melee as a combo
just try that on this group sure yeah
why haven't I been doing that more does
it work with the shield - nope didn't
get the shield out Vestal but it no more
bad guys sometimes there's like treasure
boxes that you can get like see like you
get harvest some parts crafting parts Oh
pick that up I don't know what was that
oh hey oh there's like big dudes now are
you
hey I'm nothing ,
oh maybe I'm not close enough mom or
dudes oh we got another rare let's go
Wow a nice combo yeah I did not know
that was a combo oh is that like a oh
thank you like next to them
oh not shredded Survivor that is a combo
all right that hurt
it's okay we're basically I'm just I'm
basically gonna eventually use this what
you call it ultimate on him I think he's
fond of my dad's though it's not good so
this is what I do usually I just go like
all right well I'm about to die I need
to get my health back and in doing so I
just used my alt almost all I got a ward
and then now you just get out
what I don't does that happen to anyone
else like I've had stuff despawn me and
free free roam and I don't know if it's
because did it move maybe just teleport
maybe they just teleported okay
[Music]
I'm super confused like I wanted to
fight that tank like why oh is it back
its back what the crap alright well hey
boys over here oh is it because someone
was doing quest I thing was we finished
a world event of which we got nothing
forward and this guy's at full health
buds I got a big boy here
Yolo oh yeah
the guys doing is our tiller shirt don't
worry I'll shock all the minions that
he's spawning and then we will barbecue
them
well there's a dude there hey that
should be a crit all right we're gonna
shield Paul's to mitigate damage
lightning coil seems to do way more
damage than the flamethrower
he's gonna hold
go um
Oh double blue I'm talking about I feel
like the loot drops are higher this week
or maybe I'm just getting lucky it could
be either one but I don't recall last
weekend ever getting three blues when
I'd like I did in the stronghold oh yeah
yeah I got three blues how long you're
screaming for a Guinness well I don't
know I was gonna do a couple missions
but can't sing again in a mission for
what everything combo cocoa cocoa combo
let's say like up here I found like a
box before no it's pretty evident if
there's like a box or anything like that
like around because it's like got a like
a white beam usually like I don't think
I can go that way what is your favorite
javelin oh probably stored our story
receptor like probably like everyone
else in the world oh that's a combo -
maybe you just fired melee went door in
the LA is a combo
should we try to go find some let's go
kill these brutes and then we would try
to go find a mission oh come on man guys
ruining my fun alright let's go find him
oh wait there's a chest for six members
alright let's go find a mission shall we
yeah I'm not a huge day a Grim Reaper
please don't try to promote your own
channel I'm not a huge fan of how free
roam currently works in the demo it just
doesn't feel as populated as it should
and then there's like areas that like it
if you try to go into it like Auto
teleports you but maybe that's just a
safety mechanism within the beta to keep
you out of like seeing stuff that they
don't want you to see which if that's
the case that's fine but I still feel
like there should be more like brutes
and just more scary creatures out in the
in the free roam why do you use a
controller I don't know it just feels
better for me flying
I played destiny mostly on console even
though I know pcs kind of the the gold
standard for that game it's just that my
raid crew playing on consoles so oh oh
we got another armor increase and uh we
could now try the battlecry I guess I
got a different shotgun
so let's tweak the loadout a little bit
try to hop in a mission with the
Colossus and then probably call it a
stream I think it's been a good one
thanks again to everyone tuning in today
to GameSpot live of us playing the
anthem open beta which you can get into
right now assuming you're at home and
are you know have either a PlayStation 4
Xbox one or PC you should be able to
play
what's up scorpions there got your wish
I wouldn't have to do the Forge from
there let's just do the Forge from here
do they show any story uh technically if
I hadn't already played through the VIP
demo there's some story Alberto but
since I have played through
on the VIP video mode then I can't show
it fortunately and let's go to the forge
like yeah what games are you waiting for
word 2019 um this was one of them
because I was interested as a long time
destiny player and even a division
player this so anthem division to
secular Oh shadows died twice in March
maybe jump force I guess already had
shield pulse or okay so feel like shield
pulse is better though plus 0%
electrical damage uh alright let's just
try the battle cry see how that goes
probably to be a sad boy but whatever
you wanted me to try something other
than flamethrower
I think flamethrower is fine the menu
system is awful yeah I'm not a huge fan
necessarily of the how their UI and
stuff goes but yeah I don't think I can
craft a blue grenade launcher oh I can
sick let's do that it's good good name
launcher got a blue grenade launcher
[Music]
let's look at our components so right
now I have the heaviest salt augments
which makes my so is it enhances the
heavy assault launcher to increased
damage by 10% base how much does oh it's
not as good apparently I have two of
these it's double heavy assault better
than or is it because I already have
equipped ya and equipped shucks
I guess we're taking Armour all right so
we got grenade launcher
it does have a craftable weapon system
Jeremy P asking what did you think of
Resident Evil 2 remake I didn't actually
play it but I'm not a huge re fan I
don't the the interesting thing is me I
was one of the one of the video
producers at GameSpot I only play like a
handful of games but I just play a lot
of a lot of those games
yeah crackdown 3 is in a couple weeks we
have a feature that I think just went up
today let me double check that before I
say anything yeah so if you want to know
what Peter Browns impressions of
crackdown 3 are from his kind of like
playing I think I'd like at a preview
event that's up on gamespot.com
and check that out it's interesting he
actually enjoys the multiplayer more
than the single-player but you'd have to
go see the reasons why I can't for the
life of me find any missions
hmm that's really strange cuz missions
were totally working earlier
guess we'll have to do stronghold and if
that doesn't work we might just call it
a stream our choice says what do you
what do you most want to see out of this
game come launched uh I want to see all
the crazy builds people are gonna do and
like just watch like a sick combo video
of just a really coordinated team just
like one after the other combo combo
combo combo I want to see some of the
crazy top tier gear and how that
influences gameplay I a very loot driven
person so who looks like this team's
having the struggles which is which
happens
like I can't repair
how is that even possible I feel like I
barely taken any damage
should we just wipe and start over or
can I get you I also feel like when you
read somebody you should actually get
some like life back or something but
that's maybe that's too much of a
destiny thing some why though coming up
here I am literally holding up on my
alts what I just I literally was
pressing up I wonder if it's because it
triggered the emotes there but I don't
recall hitting down but I saw the emotes
down there and I couldn't hit up to do
my alt
she's kind of unfortunate to be honest
because I was gonna use my alt skill the
turret and then pick up the Ranger there
but is that a storm that's a storm isn't
it that's weird
these guys need to kill the turrets
funny Thompson as I as you say that I
died so you know karma you guys need to
either try to revive or kill these
turrets or something oh dude this guy's
in some in a bad spot this is a bad spot
you don't want to try to revive me nor
do you want to try to revive that guy
alright now we're all dead in the same
spot I feel like that guy should just
wipe at this point and just start all
over
cuz or he should come up here freeze the
turret and then revive me so then I can
kill the turret and then we can revive
the other guy but okay well he's he's
making his way he's slowly killing the
dirt he's doing the right thing did you
get it no just broke out of freeze there
you go Yahtzee alright now he can get me
and get the rest of us it's good we
should be able to and hopefully here I
will put the shield up is that my dude
is my dude I take the risk
oh yes let's all provide them
maybe I actually don't have vault even
though it says I do because I cannot do
it whatever that's too far now awesome
now I have alts okay sure
it's fine we figured it out talk it I
mean this is just the devil Thompson so
I mean I don't think you can judge it
based just on the demo I mean in the in
the current state of things yes I'm
playing the same things
the only difference I guess you could
argue is that I've been playing
different javelins but again this is
only a slice of the game so I wouldn't
judge it just based off that now if it's
not your cup of tea it's just nice see
just fair
you gotta find more of these echoes
we're missing one sometimes people don't
realize they actually have an echo and
then they don't like turn it in maybe I
should stand okay
we're gonna do what we do best which is
cause some mayhem here with lightning
for fire abilities as you can see this
is how you like basically like sustain
your health right you're just killing a
bunch of these mobs they drop health
bust out your shields run people over
that guy just ragdoll funny
apparently lightning coil and anyway is
a combo Wow
like look at how much damage that does
right that's insane to me
whatever
I bet
get our jail card
there's no way I'm not dead yeah wow
there's a lot of stuff up should I save
that all oh I feel like I'm pretty safe
to revive but these guys are probably
frantically running around cuz there's
just stuff shooting them yeah I don't
know the the one elite guy that has the
machine gun he just says way too much
damage I think he does more damage than
the really beefy like flamethrower boy
oh we died that's not good
well we got started over
two guys left this is stronghold life I
suppose stop dying yeah trying it ain't
easy as a colossus like i said i still
feel this classes and tanky enough as it
is in the in the demo but you know what
you're gonna do like
I mean it's now it's just me and this
guy
probably not be wasting the sama on this
guy honest
I love it yeah I still think this is
like my least favorite class I had died
here because it doesn't this is it
that's about as much HP as you're
getting it back and then I basically
have to hope to find like a bunch of
like little dudes to kill which luckily
I think there's some like there which is
good
Oh what's going on oh well that's the
first time it ever crashed uh yeah
use your shield trying trying man
even even with the shield though doesn't
really matter it still takes like the
shield like runs out pretty quickly
alright well unfortunately I don't see
kind of the reason to go back into
another match so use the shield question
mark exclamation mark I got you guys
don't worry
anyways that only happened once where we
actually got like hard kicks I would say
we got logged like out of an expedition
like the end of one like once but
otherwise we got in and it was fine
check it out if you want to open demo
for anthem thank you guys and gals for
all tuning in to GameSpot live we're
live Monday to Friday 11:00 a.m. if you
didn't know you should subscribe and
you'll get notifications as to when we
go live we'll be back Monday with some
cool stuff but go try it out remember
Sunday there's a event thing going on in
anthem as well so check that out if
you're thinking about it it did crash
there side work man I had Hart crash as
I was like flying around so there's a
bunch of other stuff to play so check
that out is the Colossus any good I
think that the Colossus will can be good
I'm probably just not playing it well so
yeah if you up your army at boost shield
and HP ups your tankiness ah nice Thank
You Antoine probably just don't have the
right loadout there to make the Colossus
successful but like I said I'm sure
there's plenty of ways to play that
better and I'm sorry that I didn't do so
but thank you guys so much have a good
rest of your day I'm out enjoy your
weekend enjoy the open beta if you're
gonna check it out
bye
cyborg man community Fridays is still on
they just let us do and them bye guys